Hello Sweet bitches out there in
cyberspace or wherever you are.
Maybe you're on a treadmill right now.
Maybe you're in your car, maybe driving,
maybe a board is fuck at work. Wherever
you are, we're here for you bitches.
Well, that's the delay. That's my laptop.
That's the difference between what
I say and when it reaches you.
So think about that while this is
going on, what's you're hearing?
Is it fucking timewarp?
Okay,
it's seconds behind the actual
reality of my words. Like,
oh no asteroid at soc,
we got hit and then the power went off
and then use stream gets it five seconds
later. Well, if an astroid
hit like Arizona, it would
take a while for, we'd knew.
Well, no, not really. That's too
close. But if it hit like Sweden,
we probably wouldn't know
for like a second or two.
We'd probably would hear about it
like a week in advance though. Well,
if one of those dinosaur
killers is on the way we,
that'd be fucking looting and rioting and
there would be no more squarespace.com
like how a segue. It's like a professional
should be on the radio. Squarespace, uh,
by the way, uh, we, um, they
made a mistake in their copy
and I was wondering why,
uh,
because the Squarespace has a new
contest out and the contest is you go to
squarespace.com forward slash chuck
Joe, Joe, what's my name? Joe,
the contest is, I'll say it again.
squarespace.com, forward slash Joe signup.
Get 10% off your first purchase, then
build a website. Um, super easy to use.
Squarespace.
Brian has made literally dozens of
websites while we've been doing these
commercials and they're excellent.
It's like the,
there was a time where it was
sucky, man. It was hard. You know,
I had Andrew created some
of my, uh, my original,
Aka menthol from the quake days,
created some of my earlier a websites
and Brian created one of them,
but it's not fucking easy,
but now it is.
Now it's really easy.
You could make your own bad ass website
just with the just regular understanding
of how to use a computer drag and drop
and shit like that. Super easy to do.
And it comes out amazing.
So amazing that Squarespace
wants to have a contest. Uh,
if you can go there, go to
squarespace.com four slash Joe. Sign up,
get your 10% off your first purchase,
build a website.
Then once you got your site done,
tweeted to j r e Squarespace Hashtag j
r e Squarespace Hashtag is like the Tic
Tac toe thing. If you're like,
what the fuck is a Hashtag?
And you don't have anybody that can
tell you if you're the smartest one,
you know,
and you're an idiot,
it's very possible you could
live in like somewhere bad. Jay,
Hashtag this tic TAC toe jre Squarespace
do it before January 17th and we'll
pick four winners who have designed the
most beautiful websites. Um, Squarespace.
We'll give these went, we'll do a
whole little thing about it. We'll,
we'll examine your websites.
We even give you some props.
Maybe if it's a website for your business,
we'll start a fucking explosion.
That will lead really to a financial
windfall. You better if I said that.
Well that's Lauren.
Anyway,
these people who were in these four will
get a free year of Squarespace and we
will send those winners a swag bag with
items like a Squarespace apple keyboard,
a tee shirt,
a mole skin and more.
So visit squarespace.com right now and
use the code Joe and the number one
that's Joe and the number one.
Do that.
And then tweet your website
to Hashtag Jerry Squarespace.
Poor pound signs. Yeah, no love anymore.
It's a Hashtag now exchanged
like out of nowhere.
How come they have matured and moved
on and why did they allow that?
It's the prince.
It's probably someone who like had like
Hashtag like they own the name Hashtag
and the fucking hated the pound time.
Like that pound guys at Dick
Guy owns pound fuck pound.
It's not pallets fucking Hashtag now.
And it worked.
We're going to repurpose this
whole need for existence.
They figured out how to do it though.
That's what's amazing.
Like they pulled it off.
They actually pulled off the the Hashtag
cu and now you'll get people in the
next few years. Where kids now, why
is there a Hashtag on the phone?
What do you use this once? It's
there once it's named, it's named.
How the fuck did they change it? It's,
that's amazing. It's got confused.
So many kids.
It's going to confuse the shit out of him.
They did a really good job.
If you really looked at it from
like a conqueror standpoint,
hashtag dominated the pound sign.
We're not going to have it dialpad in
the future. I'm surprised we still do.
You know? Yeah. Most likely.
Yeah. Um, anyway, uh,
stamps.com is our other podcast sponsor.
stamps.com is where Christina Palicki
in Thompson, girl from your mom's house.
They send their stuff out using
stamps.com Bert Kreischer,
if you bought those machine tee shirts,
he sends those out through stamps.com if
you bought any of those desk squad tee
shirts from Brian Red Band,
he sends them out through stamps.com we
have massive experience with stamps.com
we love them. We trust them. We
recommend them wholeheartedly.
It is a way easier solution.
If you send things,
especially if you have a small business.
If you're like making your
own macrame or some shit,
you're doing something weird and
you want to send it out to people.
You used to have to go to the post office,
wait in line,
they weigh the different packages. Each
one's d. It takes a long fucking time.
You don't have to do it any more.
You could do it from the comfort of your
own home and if you use the code word
j, r e they will give you a free digital
scale that will get you started off.
It's super easy to do. You weigh
your packages on the digital scale.
Then you print off real us
postage from your home computer.
Slap that bitch on. Boom.
The Post Postman comes,
you give it to him and you're off.
That's it.
You cut out that whole disgusting process
of waiting in that horrifying line and
just riding your life away. Don't
do that part. Don't do that part.
Go to to stamps.com type
in the code j. R. E.
Get this special offer.
No risk trial hundred $10 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale
and up to $55 of free postage.
That's it, so go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click on the old school,
the microphone and the top of the homepage
and type J r e that stamps.com and j
r eight pitches or also brought to you
by [inaudible] dot com if you haven't
been on it for awhile.
We're constantly adding new things.
We're constantly finding new supplements,
new strength and conditioning equipment
and just do stuff that we find that we
feel is beneficial.
One of the big ones is we've started a
whole series of a artistic kettlebells
and I know a guy like Scott Sigler horror
author can appreciate that the fantasy
behind the Zombie kettle
bells or the primal bells.
The idea behind them is you will work
out harder if you really were fighting
against the fucking Zombie invasion. If
you're preparing for the Zombie invasion,
you have to keep your family alive.
You will have that extra revenue.
You will have that one extra set where
you don't want to do it anymore. And uh,
if you swing around these fully functional
Zombie Bell Kettle Bells that can,
that can give you that feeling,
they can give you that, that,
that fear that you need
to complete your workout.
My favorites of the primal bells, cause
I'm a big fan of the monkey community,
big fan of the apes. Mad shout
out to all the primates. Uh,
I just love the fact that they're artistic
and they're actually fully functional.
We Act,
we had them besides being designed and
drawn and created by this Guy Steven
Shubin Jr. We also had them
three d printed. We all,
we, we hit three d balanced.
Rather we had to make sure that when
you're swinging this kettle bell,
it'll have the same functional use as a
real kettle bell that just looks like a
smooth cannon ball.
So it's not just a design.
They work just as well as a real credible
and they will fucking last for the
rest of your life.
I mean,
look at the giant metal sculptures that
are heavy as fuck and you get to see a
look on the Postmates face
when he delivers that shit.
Like what the fuck son?
What are you doing here?
Um,
you don't even need a big one to get a
good workout in. I do one of my workouts,
the entire workouts with one 35
pound kettle bell. We sell that DVD.
That's the Keith Weber Kettle
Bell Cardio extreme workout.
It's fucking madness. That dude's a
savage. He does it with a 45 pounder.
That fucking animal.
Um,
we saw all sorts of different
things that we feel, uh,
help with a athletic performance and
what you would call functional strength.
That's the trend these days when you
see all this crossfit type stuff and all
this people that are training,
you know,
you see mixed martial arts training with
club bells and battle ropes and shit
like that.
The idea behind all of that is that in
the olden days when they used to do just
like, you know, preacher curls and you
know, things, things along those lines,
there were things that were good
and there's things that were bad,
but there was a lot of people
that were imbalanced. In a few uh,
view laugh at the,
the,
the classic meathead is the guy who is a
meatball with two toothpicks holding it
up. Guy Who's got a gigantic upper body
and a small lower body. He's not balanced.
He's not, that's not an athletic body.
That's not a body, a little work for you.
That's your, you're being silly
bitch and your tits are huge.
You don't need that in your life,
okay? You want functional strength.
Stop getting so crazy.
We sell all kinds of stuff@a.com the
best shit that we can find in any and all
forms, whether it's supplements, whether
it's strength and conditioning equipment,
whether it's food,
we even sell the best blenders for
making Kale shakes and protein shakes on
a.com o. N. N. I. T. Use
the code name. Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off any and
all supplements. All right.
Scott says we're going to get crazy.
We're going to talk
about some scary shit and
go
well,
good experience.
Oh yeah. And before we get started,
what do you, when your shows in Texas,
you got three this week.
Houston,
a Friday or Thursday,
Tony Hinchcliffe and a Tiffany Haddish.
Tiffany is going to be with our,
our only or Austin and Dallas show.
So it's a Houston.
It's going to be John toll
a funny guy.
Yeah.
Tony Hinchcliffe.
And we're doing a podcast before a show
and then the following day we're going
to be an Austin.
And then Dahlia,
so you do a live podcast,
live podcast.
Which one are you gonna
do you gonna do kill Tony?
Are you going to let like local comics go
up and shit? I, we eat. It's going to be,
we have some local girls
that work for playboy and uh,
we're just going to make it a mess.
Perfect. Yeah, bringing alcohol.
Don't try and do it. So, but yeah,
exactly. Be careful here in Texas,
they don't play games.
They party hard.
Texas parties hard and I do a
blackout podcast before the show.
I feel like you will,
whether you want to or not.
Why are you pretending like he played
on the side of some piece of art.
It's just going to be what it is.
Don't be silly son. Uh, so, uh,
where are these dates? Where
the uh, the actual clubs?
It's January or this Thursday.
It's going to be in Houston.
It's going to be at
Fitzgerald's. Uh, and then, uh,
the following day it's going to be an
Austin with Tiffany Haddish at the spider
house ballroom.
And then a Saturday it's going to
be at the curtain club in Dallas,
Texas with a squad TV
for all the info on all Brian stuff.
And that's where you can also
buy those t shirts, you know,
all the kitty cat desk squad tee shirts.
Um, I mean the Houston this weekend. No,
I'm not in Houston. I'm in Phoenix this
weekend. Jesus Christ. You're in Houston.
I'm in Phoenix. Where am I?
I'm in the valley. Um, I mean,
uh, the Phoenix standup live,
which is fucking awesome venue.
I love that place. And I'm there with
the lovely and talented Thompson Guerra,
who's one of the most fucking
hilarious dudes on the planet.
So I'm really psyched. I Love
Phoenix. Phoenix is a fun town.
They don't take themselves too seriously.
They like to party. They like to drink.
They're close enough to la. The not
retarded. They get, they get the vibe.
It's a fun place. Uh, I'll be there
this weekend with a Tommy Cigar
and then January 24th I'll be at the
Chicago theater with the Super Jew.
Are you should fear slinging Dick.
He's definitely moving. He's a,
he's going to be here for the winter.
Look, it's minus 10 in New York right now.
Cool. December, right? Yeah. I Dunno
call this. I've ever heard about it.
I never heard about minus 10 minus 10
is ridiculous, Scott Sigler. It is,
it's not necessary.
Right.
I moved away from Michigan specifically
cause I don't like minus 10. Yeah.
Or 20 or 30. Michigan's rough dude. How
you lived there your whole life. Yeah.
I live there. A write up to about,
uh, early, early thirties or so.
We're just going to after that San
Francisco, uh, that's a good place to go.
Was Dead, you know, traipse
about the country, three
months here, six months there.
Never made it out of San Francisco
is a big difference between the,
the general mentality of
Michigan versus San Francisco.
It's very unusual when you go to two
places that are so completely different.
You Go,
oh look,
this can happen to a bunch of people
can just act like this or you know,
you can go to like Vancouver or something
where everybody's nice and friendly
and you're like,
okay,
you could just be in this weird town
where everybody's nice and friendly or you
could go to Boston and they want to
beat the fuck out of your way. Like, Oh,
you know,
this could happen to there really there
really is a cultural signature to every
place. The difference between Michigan
and San Francisco was pretty dramatic.
What did that feel like when
you made that transition?
All of a sudden you're around all
these like I mean San Francisco,
super liberal and really
like open minded about,
I mean I always feel like as far as like
socially when you look at the entire
country, like as far as like the most
progressive parts of the country,
you have the coasts always, you know, the,
the most progressive, but at all of them,
San Francisco seems to
be the most extreme,
the first to be like super
accepting of gays. The first,
I mean the whole Berkeley psychedelic
movement, all that shift from the CFTS,
the echoes of that still feel like
they're hanging around that place.
And it's even changing again now with
all of that.co texts version on the tech
people and rents are rising and
real estate's never really slow.
I mean it leveled out
at a couple of places,
but it's never dropped and it's
come back up. And um, you know,
the inability for people working a regular
job to even be able to afford to live
in a city is worse now. So it's the
whole, I think the whole liberal,
just salt of the places is changing again
and now it's just becoming about money.
You're totally right. Yeah. The real
estate prices there are fucking crazy.
Yup. There was a, there's one neighborhood
that I was looking at. I was just a,
I was there visiting a friend. I was
like, wow, this place is beautiful.
It's like near San Jose.
This houses were like a regular,
it was like a regular house and it
was $9 million. Yeah. And I was like,
what the fuck is that? That's a regular
house. It's not even a crazy mansion.
It's a beautiful house,
but it's just a house house house.
The biggest shock we had was,
uh,
we came to San Francisco and start looking
around and one of the places phones,
literally, it converted. It's a one
bedroom apartment that is now a tenancy
in common or a condo and it's a
one bedroom bout 750 square feet.
It was $800,000.
And I had worked in Michigan for a
company that built homes and for basically
for 800 grand in Michigan. You own
everything you see. Yeah. Like God,
you have like one of those Ted
Nugent compounds. You've got,
you've got your own herd of elk on campus.
It's just nuts and that that's a one
bedroom and it really hasn't changed all
that much since then, but you'd have
to live in Michigan to ignore it,
to enjoy it rather. Yeah, well, yeah,
you have to like 10 below and there's,
you know, there's no comparison for the
cultural broadness of San Francisco.
There's a ton of crap to do there
and a ton of things to experience.
I don't know. That's worth 800,450 square
foot apartment, but it's pretty sweet.
Yeah. That's a bizarre thing when the
amount of wealth in an area and becomes so
concentrated that regular
people just can't live there.
He just literally can't afford to.
It's getting crazier and crazier because
there's so many people that have made a
lot of money and technology and they,
they're centered around that area.
I mean the amount of wealth,
the concentrated amount of
wealth in San Francisco,
just tech wealth is,
and a lot,
a lot of stuff's coming up from silicon
valley now back in his San Francisco and
that close enough that I feel like
it's the same thing. It's pretty,
it's pretty similar now there's even
protesters blocking like the Google bus,
the Google buses that pick up all the,
the 20 something Ivy League graduates
who are just wicked, wicked, smart,
hardworking people who go to work for
Google and they get on their bus with
their Wifi.
You know,
it's so it's perfect little limo bus and
then you've got regular working class
Joe's parking in front of it
with a picket sign and you know,
sometimes rattling the bus or throwing
stuff at the bus. They're really,
people are blaming the silicon valley
tech companies for the rents rising to the
point where if you just want
to work at like a bookstore,
if that's what you're calling is,
you want to do that.
You can't afford to live
in the city at all anymore.
Those people are are super mad that
they can't live where they want to live.
It's a, it's a strange
situation. That's very strange.
I don't think I can recall any place
where that's happened before that I know
about. I can't think of it.
I can't think of it either.
But you know to be one of these people
on the bus and all of a sudden you know
the populous is rising up against you
in burning torches and banging signs
against the bus. That's got to be pretty
scary. Yeah, and all you there is working.
Yeah.
They're trying to do what you gone to
school for and which you're practicing
with. People are so
fucking strange. It's hard.
It's super hard for the people
working in these companies to relate.
I think because I've had the opportunity
to go do a couple things in the Google
campus with a company I used to work for
and they are super hardworking people.
Super Nice,
really creative and clever.
I mean all of these cultures are very
open and letting people pursue what they
want to pursue and they, they just
bust their ass. They work really hard,
so it's how you can't really relate.
I have a good friend who works for Google,
she loves it there. I think that what
you're dealing with when you, you,
you see a situation like this
is this insane new wealth,
the this insane tech
wealth,
this industry that it's over the last
couple of decades become so gigantic
because the amount of money that
it generates is just freakish.
When you think about like cell phones,
think about any other product
that you sell. You know,
you might have one and this guy might
have while like say if you make like a
vacuum sealers for food,
I like to keep my vegetables fresh.
How many of those are going to sell, sell,
sell phones though? You're going to sell
ah, fuck clothes they catch on. Yeah.
[inaudible] of people on the planet.
Like the amount of money you can make if
you sell cell phones is fucking beyond
comprehension, right? Well, they're,
they're, they're like one of these,
like how many of these,
and they saw the lumber barons and the
steel barons and the oil barons of all
the, all those different times
and it history. One bigger.
The Vanderbilts came out and just had
in crazy amounts of money and all the
steel and everything else.
It's exactly the same thing.
It's this brand new thing that all of
the world needs and it's controlled by a
limited amount of people, but the
people are smart as fuck. Yeah,
it's really a good, good
amount of Pete. You know,
if you're going to be controlled by the
right amount of people or the right kind
of people, the Google people,
not bad robots though.
Now they've got a share per kilo.
They're preparing because seriously, man,
if other people get killed,
the robots
first, we've got a real problem.
It's the Oppenheimer dilemma.
Do you make the atomic bomb knowing it's
going to kill millions of people or do
you let the Russians make it first and
kill millions of people over here or the
Germans rather?
It's the same dilemma.
Well Google Google's cutting out the
middle or the government, just like,
we're going to be able to protect
our own stuff. It'll be fine.
What do you think Google?
Yeah,
Google is going to start buying arms
companies next or making their own.
The robotics people like, oh, I
know a couple of people. You know,
I make a robot dog, but I also know Mike,
Mike, my neighbor, he makes missiles.
When would you guys want to do things?
Thinking that you could fucking hiring
the greatest engineers of our day to
build missiles for Google?
Come over. We'll have a kegger.
We'll put all this stuff together.
And one day in like 2024 Google just
shows up at the Federal Reserve and Gos
stop. It's over yet. Get
Out. Everybody get out.
We run things now. We don't want,
when I want your money anymore.
Does it mean anything incredibly?
I mean,
this is not conspiracy theory to
say it's not all that far fetched.
If they buy up the weapons,
making technology and have all this stuff,
their ability to influence policy could
get pretty, pretty significant. So
our ability to,
uh,
to first of all as citizens to,
to recognize that we're getting screwed
over on a daily basis and also recognize
that the government is invading our
privacy on a daily basis. You know, when,
when people start recognizing those
kinds of things and you'll look at the,
like some of the, some of the lawsuits
that had been brought up against people,
some of,
uh,
some of the people that have lost like
giant chunks of their time and their life
fighting off the government,
whether it's because of taxes or because
of regulations or whatever the fuck it
is.
If you stopped and thought
like engineering that and
making it the way it is,
you would never, you'd never design
it this way. That's the way it is.
It's so gross. And the IRS can
go after people that, you know,
if you don't pay your taxes,
they just throw you in prison.
They want you to be so scared that you
have to pay them their money if you don't
pay them their money,
they treat you as if you're a dangerous
criminal that you have to take out of
society. And lock in. You are a
dangerous criminal to them. They're,
they're an organization and a company
just like anybody else. And if it gets,
if the information gets
out there that yeah,
there's really no repercussions
for you not giving us our revenue,
then they're screwed. Then
enough people say, yeah,
we're not paying you and you've lost
your income and your company goes under.
Did you hear about the beanie
babies thing? No. The guy
who created beanie babies,
he paid $1 billion in taxes and they're
like, hmm. Not Enough. What I like,
we need like 1,000,000,005 million.
He hid some, some money somewhere.
He had some money. This mother Fucker,
if he paid $1 billion in taxes,
he's probably on coke all day.
It has no idea how much money he has.
Probably nothing to do. Nothing to do with
this thing. You know, like hiding money.
Like, what are you talking to please
fucking made beanie babies. He's not like,
you know, he's not a nuclear
engineer. He's a crazy fuck.
That made something that for some reason
made him so much money that he paid $1
billion in taxes.
But they're like,
that's the look that one up
and he dd to pay some more.
That's a lot of money in taxes.
You think $1 billion in taxes would be
for frigging beanie babies would be good.
It's ridiculous.
It's completely ridiculous.
So when Google takes over
and skynet goes live,
you know that guy will get his money back.
That is all the Federal Reserve pay him.
Google's the Robin Hood of Beanie baby
founders. But uh, maybe would she,
I mean I don't think it's outside the
realm of possibility that our government
and our,
not just our government,
but our military is run through technology
and just a few years to the point
where it's gonna get real gray.
Whether or not like who has power?
Is it going to be country?
Is it going to remain countries?
Is it going to eventually
shift into corporations?
Are Corporate entities and we were talking
about like how much money there is in
technology and creating things
at a certain point in time.
The technology is going to reach the
point where people can essentially do
whatever the fuck they want. You
know, there's the ongoing question is,
are the corporation is actually running
things now already as the government
come relatively puppet structure based
on who's pumping the most campaign money
in et cetera.
And now you're talking about artificial
intelligence coming into the place.
I say yes, yes, yes.
And I think it's absolutely the case
of the corporations have gotten to an
insanely influential place,
insanely powerful ability to control
the results of elections and the,
the way the world works.
I mean it's really incredible,
but what's most incredible is that
it's a bunch of people, corporations,
just a bunch of people,
bunch of people are doing some things.
It's like really bad for humanity can
make you fuck loads of money for the
corporation, for the
corporation. You at it from, you
know, the artificial organism
structure of a corporation.
You know how low the Coca Cola company
has been alive longer than any human
being on the planet. You know,
and now you've got whatever these,
and it's a lot like the means of
religion or, or national nationalism.
These structures,
the self replicating and self supporting
structures have been built up and they
live longer than we do.
So now corporations, yeah,
well they're not people,
but at the same time,
that's a successful organism right there
and it's fighting to stay alive and
dominate how it wants to dominate. Yeah,
that's the real skinny on it, right?
It's a thing. It's a system.
It's an operating entity and it,
it's made out of people, but it really
likes money more than it likes people.
I mean,
it's really amazing that people have
created something that's not entirely self
serving and it protects itself as it
weird structure of ones and Zeros and
buildings and paper. And it's, to me,
it's really a borderline organism
because it's a, as a collective organism,
all of the people working within it,
there's a certain pattern of behaviors
that have led to those corporations being
successful and living for a hundred
years or longer and only people who are
following those patterns of
behaviors mostly are going
to be successful in there.
So it's self perpetuating. So you've
got this certain type of behavior,
which has always put the company first,
screw the rule of screw people,
go out and make things
profitable that works.
So these companies grow and continue to
live and spawn off other companies and
it just keeps on going. So I mean,
to me they're, you know, they're,
they're not living organisms only
by a technicality of definition.
That's a fascinating way of looking at it.
Now as an author,
when you see something like this that
you see may perhaps like a good majority
of the people have probably overlooked
you when you look at it like that.
I mean that's, it's, it's got to seem
like almost like a work of fiction.
I mean if,
if,
if the system in and of itself like the
way it's constructed now and just the
idea of sending people to go kill people
they don't even know on the other side
of the world,
like all of it is just so bizarre.
If it didn't exist in this form and
someone brought it to you as a script,
you'd be like, whoa. To
fucking cooperate. It's a lie.
It's alive and it's eating. People look
at how many people the corporation comes.
Oh my God, it's eating
painful. Yeah. Well you know,
even going back to the sky net concept of,
you know,
that's science fiction 25 years ago and
you are now getting to the point with
the globe, you know, the,
the global nature of the
Internet and everything else.
If you were able to get some kind of
powerful online entity or an artificial
intelligence that's not at
all far fetched anymore,
that somebody could control everything,
not even a little. So it seems inevitable,
right? I don't know about inevitable.
It's definitely, definitely possible.
The leap from having a system that can
communicate everywhere all over the world.
At one time and then jumping to
something that can actually make its own
decisions and decide its own destiny.
I think that's an,
I know very little about it but
that's way bigger than people think.
It's not just,
oh we're going to make this smart
robot and it will go through and make
decisions.
You know,
self determination is a whole different
ballgame that they haven't been able to
tackle yet. So, uh, I it,
it's definitely possible. It
doesn't seem inevitable to me.
To me it seems inevitable.
It seems inevitable just based on
the exponential growth of technology,
meaning the, you know, one
equals two and two posts,
one he's three and then three
plus two is five. When you,
when you start seeing how quickly
things are developing and how quickly
technology is improving and enhancing,
you realize that like if we were in a
horror movie and there was a horror movie
about robots that eventually took over
and just start raping people and eating
them, it would probably start off a
lot. Like what we're seeing on the news.
We'd have like quick flashes of like a
new robot technology and then six months
later Sony releases another one and then
five months after that they create some
sort of an artificial brain cell that
actually works better than a real brain
sale.
They started inserting them into people's
bodies and then you cut to 50 years
later,
apocalyptic nightmare scenario,
robots eating cinder blocks, you
know, running down the street,
finding the last vestiges of humanity,
hiding under sewer pipes. You know, my,
my hope isn't whatever does come down
to that. There's still, you know,
people are really good at doing labor
and figuring things out and they also
breed and make more copies of themselves.
So if you're a robot,
artificial intelligence
killing all the peoples,
a complete and utter waste of time,
why would you do that?
Here's this relatively free labor pool
that makes more copies of itself and
continues to do what you want.
Which goes back to the concept of coke,
the Coca Cola brand or IBM or British
companies that are five and 600 years old.
You know,
that's sort of already happening.
There are self determined
human being sourced,
serving the greater purpose
of the overlord organization.
So your artificial intelligence
could easily be like that.
So I'm hoping that when we get taken over
they'll just want to give us jobs and
they'll want us to be happy workers.
I think they'll find us so inefficient
and stupid. They'll want to eat us.
I mean to think they'll treat us
the same way we treat chimps. Yeah.
Like shut the fuck up and get in the cage.
I think if they use us at all,
they'll have like a show that amuses them.
Well they'll have the,
these are actual real people.
This the last of the real people.
We keep them in his cage, make them
fuck but treat them like killer whales.
Here's the music.
Here's a museum to show you the way
things once were a long time ago,
people needed food. Ha ha ha. Everybody
will laugh. They'll think it's hilarious.
They'll think natural people are just
ridiculous. The idea of a natural person,
it can easily become redundant.
And this is a trope that's played
on science fiction all the time.
And I have it in some of my books too,
which is once you get your artificial,
uh,
race or artificial intelligence, the
point where it can reproduce on its own,
when robots can make
other versions of itself,
that's when we're no longer necessary.
When something can breed
to make copies of itself.
And I'm not necessarily talking
a big factory crank things out,
although that works when robots can
basically basically make baby robots that
harvest energy and resources from the
environment and get bigger and become an
adult and fully functional and
capable of carrying work, then
we're screwed. There's no
need for us anymore. Just
competition at that point. He,
as soon as they figured out
how to make better robots,
like you guys made a fucking
terrible design with us.
Let's just fix all of that.
I mean, I wonder if we're arrogant
and thinking that our, our, uh,
special abilities as people,
whether it's our emotions,
our creativity or whatever,
that they're actually really special
and that they're not replicable.
But what if robots are like, oh dummy,
it's so easy to make something like you.
Yeah. Like you're not even that
complex you guys are based on like,
it's really pretty obvious emotions,
very predictable behavior
patterns under stress.
Like you guys are fucking simple.
You like,
you like to thank your super
complicated cause it makes you happy.
Well there's all this stuff we've always
thought was complicated or impossible
and the now we do all the time and yeah,
somebody at some point could crack the
chemical code of our behavior be like,
oh he just mixed a little bit of this,
a little bit of that boom.
Next thing you know he's crying.
This robot's crying cause he got his
heartbroken at the prom and then boom,
blade runner, blade runner. Then
those scenes with Rutger Hauer.
What'd your Howard is dying and he
doesn't want to kill Harrison Ford,
but he was thinking about killing him.
But he,
he loves and respects life
so much so he doesn't,
he winds up ultimately not killing him.
That's a fucking powerful movie, man.
And not far off from what would actually
happen if you had something and you
engineered emotions into it. And
if he didn't, then what do you got?
You got to fucking city filled with
robot psychos that have no emotions.
You would want to engineer all the same
flaws that people have if you wanted to
create artificial people when in fact if
you did that, wouldn't they be a person?
Yeah. Wouldn't they be subject to
jealousy and poor decision making?
And there's everything outside of
drugs cause they would be robotic.
I'm sure they'd have their own
robotic drugs of some kind. You know,
various buyers isn't reprogramming
and anything you want,
but they'd probably the point battery
or batteries at some point. It, well,
when they put their tongue of the battery,
it's a whole different experience.
At some point it would become
indiscernible. You couldn't
tell the difference. Um,
gosh, I'm forgetting it.
But there's that, uh,
something test where you put a blindfold
and put a blind between people.
And if you can't tell the person on the
other end of that computer is a robot or
a person as a human being, you
can't tell, am I talking to a robot?
Am I talking to human being texts for him
in Texas and Warren voice or text form.
But if you get to that point,
that's one of the definitions of we
have gotten closer achieved artificial
intelligence. When you as a
human can't tell the difference,
that's when you're really close to that.
And a emotions would be a big
part of that in the movie.
It will show people talking into
their phones, asking Siri questions,
googling things and while they're driving
so it'll show those sort of things
like that. They willingly
accepted into the robot fold.
We're letting them in. We as no question.
Yeah, we're completely symbiotic now.
Completely leave your phone at home. It's
like you left your Dick Behind. Yeah.
Like what do I do now?
Do not leave home without my Dick,
so I'm going back for that. Good.
Yes. Keep my phone screwed on. Yeah,
and before long they're going
to come up with some solution.
It runs on your own body's energy,
no longer needing to charge
itself in the wall. You
know, you could always get it
surgically removed and like, hey honey,
I can always get it surgically
removed and next thing you know,
you've got some robot patch on your arm
that you're dialing and it goes straight
into your ear. It's calming, it's
calming implants or the next.
That's the next big wave of,
of all of these things that
we carry on all the time.
We're going to have a little
USB ports on our forearms,
stick it in that little
wireless man. Everything will
be wireless. Ocular ocular,
either contact lenses or
inserts below the IRS.
I would suggest you see everything.
You turn your Wifi off.
His people are going to hack you. Yup. You
don't want that. Why? This is not good.
If you're going to match,
it's going to have to be hardwired.
We're going to need ports within a matrix.
Ports, Lazy. That's like you want that.
You want the Matrix sport.
Everybody else can be like, man,
I got to reach this from here to
there and plug it in. Screw that.
Just give me a wireless option. Do you
really think that people are that lazy?
Oh God, it's ridiculous. There's
plenty of people probably lazy.
There's plenty of people that would plug
their headset in that I think there are
vastly more who would totally go at.
People were a lazy,
lazy bunch as a species,
but they got to that point where they're
not willing to like plug something into
their heads. It's going to let them, do
you know, anybody who's ever complain,
they can't find like the remote control
I have to get up and change the channel
or something like that or it just
helps you. But I think there's more,
there's less people than that. Less
people like that. Then we would like, see,
this is seditious talk you're having now.
You're one of the people wants to plug in.
You don't want the wireless.
They're going to be what Google
will be watching you, sir. Um, no,
I don't mind the wireless look.
Ultimately it's all going to be,
it's going to be probably Tesla fired.
You know,
like Tesla wanted to have
electricity in the atmosphere.
You want to broadcast electricity and
Westinghouse found out what he's trying to
do and like get the fuck out of
here and they shut his program down.
His idea was to wildly transmit
electricity. The same way people wire,
you know, they, they transmit radio
waves or transmit wifi signals,
right?
He was going to wirelessly
have electricity fucking
floating around us in some
strange way. I don't, I mean I don't
even understand the technology behind it,
but I assumed that if it was
Nikola Tesla that came up with it,
this was legit stuff that's
never been picked up. So he,
he wanted to give it away.
What's the other frame?
And that's the corporations
going back to that talk,
the self defense mechanism
of the corporations kicks in.
If there's a resource that's
being given away for free,
any corporation providing that resource
is in danger of being diminished or
being destroyed.
So the natural reaction of the group mind
of the people in the company is we got
to shut that shit down right now.
This is some Alex Jones talk
doing on us, but we, you know,
we seen it with the Edison
company and their reaction to the,
to Tesla and trying to find ways to
stop this technology from coming out.
Cause if the technology comes out,
they no longer have that giant cash cow
and that's, that's worth fighting for.
What was the downside?
Was there any downside proposed downside
to projecting electricity in the air?
Do you have any idea?
I don't know that much about it.
I'm not sure that he had
proven it in a large scale.
Like can it really transfer over
long distances and be economically
viable?
And then there's just the general shock
of people seeing bolts of lightening
flashing across the countryside.
They're not very comforted by it even
though it's exactly the same thing
happening. You just can't see it because
it's in a wire. Is that what it would be?
You would see the electricity, I'm
pretty sure that's, that's what it was.
It was just blasting
things through the air.
I mean you probably have to get refilled
like a lightning bolt hits your house
every time you need more electricity.
It's scary. What about a bird?
What if a fucking bird was flying by
right when you hit the power switch?
I don't know. They burns me just
exploding off through the sky.
All throughout cities.
Birds are birds are the collateral
damage of the power industry.
They're getting killed by
wind mills right now, so,
but could you imagine if people were just
turning on their lights? Switches in.
Birds are just exploding.
This guy cause of bolts of electricity
would come out of your house and connect
you to the tree.
You know the big metal lightening tree,
some poor burb just be in that path. It
boom. You tough living for the birds.
You'd be walking down the street
and birds exploding over your head.
Birds would just start walking and they
become one of us like a dog or you know,
flying. They would read
eventually. It's good point.
That would eventually
realize through evolution,
the robots team up with the birds
and then we're really screwed.
Sort of like how butterfly develops
that fake eyeball on his wings to make a
prayer. Listen Bitch, I'm
looking at you. You know,
they're not really looking at their,
their stupid butterflies. Yeah.
Nature developed that. That was, it
became good for that. Designed to exist.
You know what a bizarre thing that is
and you just stop to think about it.
Like how do you explain that? Just
they develop eyeballs and their wings,
they just happen.
There's those pictures.
There's some mutation where they have a
pattern on their wing that makes them,
that reacts with the Predator.
The Predator looks at it and goes,
that either looks like something I've
eaten that tastes horrible or that looks
like something bigger than me and
it's dangerous. And then that,
that butterfly continues on and it
happens again and again and again.
That's the scientific explanation,
but I think there's
something nefarious at foot.
So I think something is afoot,
something studious.
I don't trust them fucking butterflies.
I don't trust them.
They're up to something. They made
eyeballs on their wings. I just,
I have a hard time believing that was
just some sort of a random setting.
It's more disturbing as the
caterpillar with eyeballs on its,
but it like listens ass up and
it's got two big eyes on there.
I don't like butts looking back at me.
I don't want to, I'm not buying it. No.
Find ones that have eyeballs. There's a,
there's some incredible ones where they,
they look like like it looks
like cat size. Yeah. That's,
it's so weird. It's, it seems
like someone's trolling us. I see.
It seems like more evidence that the
world is made out of magic and somehow or
another,
some insect is able to develop these
camouflage eyeballs on its wings that are
just fence. The robot's already took
over. We're already experiment now.
They're like,
we got,
we're going to keep giving him something
and sooner or later they're going to
figure this out.
They get the eyeballs,
like they've got to figure it out
now they've got to know it. Yeah.
We just make the world's so preposterous
that everybody just stops and goes,
wait a minute, what the fuck is going
on? And then Dan [inaudible], the music
starts playing like the curtain draws
and the aliens come out clapping. Well,
we didn't think it was going to take
you this long guy go, there's no,
people were all looking at that. There's
the owl eyes. Oh yeah, that's nuts.
We're all in the matrix. I've never seen
that one before. Harold Brown Matrix.
Look at those. I'm like the first
reaction I have looking at that,
that's gotta be Photoshop is that,
that's for as a whole series of them,
there's a bunch of different kinds of
moths or butterflies rather develop these
eyeballs on the, on the back
of their wings. So fantastic.
I just love the beauty. Yeah, amazing.
Like a cat. Those are cat's eyes.
That's looks like a tiger. It looks
like a baby tiger hiding in the woods.
Ready to Jack you so you
better step birdie. Don't
beat me. I'm a fucking tiger.
Frigging amazing. It's incredible.
I mean, look, it has eyeballs.
If you look in the eye,
it looks like,
like if you had that tattooed on you
and it was an eye, you'd be like, oh,
that artist is good. Yeah, that's a good
look at that. Get the fuck out of here.
Just get the fuck out of here. It's a
cartoon fairy. Totally. That's so weird.
And that's real. I don't buy that.
That's, I mean, I know that's the answer.
I know science would tell you that's the
answer, but they didn't see it happen.
There's no, there's no actual
documentation of that particular change.
This man chick in the world,
my friend as an author,
I'm sure you must agree with me, you,
you create fantastic works of fiction.
You create an entire worlds in your
own mind. Well, you get into, you know,
the definition of magic can be so broad.
And the fact that any one of us being
alive at this particular moment is such an
astronaut.
The odds against you being here and
living this long are so astronomical.
You can't even calculate it.
But here you are.
If we were just here a couple
of hundred years ago. Yeah.
And the fact that we've really only come
into our modern day culture in the past
two centuries or so.
So there's a lot of things I look
at as an author are just staggering.
And even looking at something
like the butterflies, of course,
my first reaction is always,
what can I do with that?
How can I work that into a story?
Because that's real and that's cool and
we can do something with it. But yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of things I look at and
even having a decent knowledge of science
and evolution and those things,
you look at it and go,
how the fuck could that happen?
There's a lot of times I find myself
arguing myself like, no, yeah, I'm not.
The one that gets me is like the
crabs that put crap on their shell.
Have you ever seen these things?
They put crap on these crabs will grab
whatever happens to be around them and
then use the their saliva and glue it
to their claws like a boxer crat and in
the glue it'll glue anatomies, which
are deadly to it, onto its claws.
So if another Predator comes up,
they're like, they put up their dukes,
they put up two and enemies,
look up boxer crab.
If you guys want to show this wards
off predators and now you can see that
anything with that behavior of course as
a survival advantage, that makes sense.
But at what point does some crazy crap
eat a bad piece of fish and get so high
that it's like,
I'm gonna go,
come gonna cut this off here and put
this on a closet and waving around for a
little. So I see stuff like that. That's
one that always throws me for a loop.
Like how did that first actually
happen? That and, and you know,
when I talked to my science consultants,
they break it down into finer and finer
detail. Once you say, makes perfect sense.
However, he's got frigging seeing enemies
on his claws. I'm not buying it, bitch.
Look at this. They taught him how to
do that. The power, the pump on grab,
that's a live in enemy on his claws and
anybody screws with them is going to get
a mouthful of nomadises
that is up to crazy. Yeah.
The ocean itself might as well
be an alien world. I mean,
it really might as well be on
another planet. Yeah. Just stopping.
Oh, that's one thing that I really
wanted to talk about with the ocean.
This is a crazy fucking thing than I just
discovered. You know, a sea shepherd,
you know, that, uh, those companies
that go out and fight those whalers, um,
they caught this Japanese whaling
ship and the Japanese whaling ship,
they have this really sneaky thing they're
doing where you are allowed to under
some provision,
some unilateral agreement.
You're allowed to whale hunt.
You could take a whale if
it's for scientific research.
So they left in some weird
loophole for scientific research.
So what these guys do is they go out
and they slaughter these whales and then
they say it's for scientific
research and they just sell the meat.
Like they're wailing it
just killing these whales.
But the way they're doing it
is under this weird loophole.
So they're selling some part of the whale,
maybe for science and then selling.
Now there's a salad.
The meat for food. They're
selling it as, I mean there's,
they're selling it commercially,
but you can see the, uh, the photos.
Did you see the, uh, the images, Brian,
if you go to like sh sea shepherd, uh,
one of the more recent stories about
it, you could, they have, they took,
they've got a helicopter and they flew
over the boat and took photos of these
dead whales.
There it is just sitting on it's dark man.
It's really dark.
And um,
if you look as they pull back and they
show you there's a website address and if
you go to that website address,
there's an English version and an American
and a Japanese version. But the, uh,
the, the images are pretty shocking
if you go and look at it online,
they even have video of them slaughtering
one of the whales. But to me,
when I look at that,
that to me is just like us
going to another planet and
killing some alien being.
We would never stand for that.
If we showed up on Mars and Mars had
wheels on it and we just started gutting
whales and using it for scientific
research, people would go fucking crazy.
Like what are you doing? We found this
intelligent life form that communicates,
it has a voice, it has language, it has,
they have some sort of a
weird differentiation between
different sections of the
world and they have different accents.
Yeah.
But at the same time,
if there's a resource there that we need
or someone can make money from and the
propaganda machine kicks in and we find
this alien intelligence and then your
president is on the radio,
this is a significant danger to the
human race and we have to act right now
cause they do all of
these horrible things.
We've watched it on our planet dozen
times in our own lifetime where somebody
comes out with a propaganda machine and
we're so manipulatable that we'd be like,
oh well if we don't bomb them first,
they're going to bomb us. We are scared.
People get scared. Especially
when they have kids. Yeah. Kids,
I get real scared and they
want to just fucking bomb them.
They're dangerous out there. The martians
have weapons of mass destruction.
We got to take them bitches out.
But imagine if we went to Mars,
we found some intelligent life forms
that communicate with language and we
decided to start eating them.
Imagine the protest.
Imagine how bad people would freak out.
But we don't have any problem. The whales,
whales pretty much aren't hurting anybody.
We've established that they aren't
hurting anybody. So not hurting anybody.
And smart. We know that. We
know those two things for sure.
But you know what the thing is?
Nature's so evil herself,
like nature sets whales up.
It makes it so whales can't
defend themselves against
killer whales. You know?
That's why they call him killer whales.
A lot of folks don't know that they kill
whales. They're not whales or dolphins,
but they kill whales.
They're in the you,
the videos of them killing
whales are fucker. Crazy,
crazy cause they know it doesn't,
they don't do it quick. You know,
like they just started eating
this, chewing off a hug. I,
the one I saw when I was a little kid
who was a national geographic and the
first time anybody had ever documented
an Orca pack taking out a whale could
have been, I can't remember
what kind of whale it was,
gray whale or sperm whale
and they literally chew on
it until it opens its mouth
like in pain and then one swims inside
the mouth and starts non down on the
tongue. Oh God. Cause that's,
and as far as they could tell
like that's the good stuff.
That's what they actually want
is the tongue tastes the best.
So somebody gets to go in there and start
chewing on that tongue and then they
just, they just kill it. It's hard to
take their side. That's a cunty fish.
Obviously it's hard to
take the killer whale side.
I mean I would like to take their side,
but the way they treat whales is fucked.
And then you realize, well you know that's
just nature. Nature is just like that.
There's going to be,
it's going to be horrific crimes.
That's what nature is all about. Nature.
Nature is an endless fight for survival.
And if you aren't killing,
then you're going to get
killed and yeah, that it goes.
And if you have no way of
recognizing your culture,
if you have no way of objective
Lee assessing your, your situation,
if you're stuck in a world where you
need constant movement, even to breathe,
you're constantly, I mean they're,
they're carrying a lot of body mass.
You need to get fish and they
need to feed all the time.
So they're constantly in movement. They
don't have any time for self reflection.
They don't have a fucking couch with
a kickback with their pipe and watch
masterpiece theater and
ponder and write poetry.
And then that poetry
can be read by others.
And if we existed in a world like that,
we were just flying around
the three dimensional space.
I don't think we'd be very much different
than dog. Well, we weren't. And it's,
it's the development of agriculture and,
and society and,
and cities and getting that safety
that comes in in with a large number of
people working together.
That's the only thing that's
allowed to do those things as well.
You go back 40 50,000 years with us
and it was, there was no different,
we'll kill anything that moves,
kill and kill and eat anything that moves,
and if you don't do it,
something's going to kill you.
And it was only the development of society
that allowed people to start writing
poetry and making art and
doing all those other things.
Yeah. The development of a place where
you can hang out and not get eaten. Yeah.
And where you had food
stockpiled and you're like, okay,
I've got all that covered. Yeah. I got a
wall. I got a gun, I got a steak. Okay,
I'm good. I got nothing to do for at least
the next week. And next thing you know,
you're drinking wine
and writing things down,
and then people read that shit
and go, dude, I thought that too,
but I just never put it to words. And
then the whole culture expands from there.
Yeah. That's never going
to happen with dolphins.
They've got to keep moving ever
going to like shit, dolphins,
I don't think they're very much
different than us. I know. I know.
That's a very hippie thing to say,
but I had a experience once on a boat
with dolphins playing wild dolphins in
Hawaii. It changed me for life, changed
me for life, just looking in their eyes,
experiment,
experiencing like laughing with them and
yelling at them and them doing tricks
for you.
I mean they was when they were with us
for over an hour and I was high as fuck
God damn, I was high, I was so hot. I
definitely shouldn't have been on a boat.
But there I was.
And when you're that high,
you're very vulnerable and
very sensitive and very,
very introspective and almost
painfully so sometimes.
So me looking in the eyes of though
that Dolphin had me absolutely convinced
just watching these things play,
that I'm probably being
extremely prejudice and how
highly I value human human
cognition and our ability to change our
environment being the ultimate measure
of intelligence.
Well they, they, they couldn't
change her environment.
They have absolutely no need to because
the African adapted to their environment.
They're perfect.
We don't have to worry about sharks.
They don't have to worry about shit.
All they have to worry about is those
conti killer whales. Whales eat them.
That's what's interesting about dolphins.
They're one of the few species on the
planet that kill for fun because they've
got so much brainpower. They're like,
I'm just going to go kill that. They'll,
they'll kill other dolphins.
They'll infanticide.
If you know there are baby dolphins
that aren't produced by them,
they'll kill him. Dolphins, rape, which
is messed up, one of the few species,
it goes down and raped.
So with big brains comes big problems.
I guess all species kind of raped. I don't
know. I don't think so. No, it's not.
It's not a very common,
it's not a very common thing.
You're heard about the
puffer fish right there.
The getting high with puffer fish,
but like champs to chimps. Rape.
The chimps do too. Yeah, they
will. Yeah. And what about cats?
Can't cause the female cats are too
bad ass. That's a dangerous move.
I don't think you want to go there.
Yeah. Fuck that. You get cut up.
He's a fucking her cue.
You mentioned tried to rape a lion.
You'll get in in pack animals.
You'll get drive,
it's driving out the Alpha male of
the pack and then the new new guys,
the Alpha Male,
and he gets the spoils of war so to speak.
But I don't think there's an enormous
amount of of straight up rape in the
animal kingdom outside of the hype.
More intelligent animal.
Well it's also, there's probably
no social stigma to fucking,
and probably the female tigers
want to have sex as well,
so there's not as much of a need
to fuck or to a rape each other.
Doesn't that make sense?
Like if wild animals,
if it just became real rapey like a
rabies, they would never eat anything.
They wouldn't get any work done.
Right. It could be, you know,
speaking out of my ass here,
but the dolphin that could be
part of that free time thing.
That's our whole shows.
They don't have anyone in 36 episodes.
No significant predators other than
humans. They don't even really,
they're not even really all that afraid
of sharks and they don't have to worry
about their environment.
The perfectly adapted and they are smart.
So they got time to think
about stuff like, you know,
look at the dorsal fin on that girl.
You know, like maybe they think
too much welded the killer whales don't
give a fuck if they think they'll eat
them. Yeah. They go around eating
dolphins, they kill everything. Yeah.
They're the best. They don't
care. They know they're smart
and like, so what? Yeah.
So you're smart to fuck you so you're not
a fish. Oh you so you breathe air. Yeah.
It seems like everything's smart
breeds they're interesting.
Nothing smart figured out gills. Uh, no.
It's all my millions.
It's all a marine mammals.
There's some people who think that the
octopus and squids are really wicked
smart,
like being,
being able to be tool users and figure
out puzzles significantly. But yeah,
that's the only quantic breathing
animal that I can think of.
Here's the problem with that argument.
They don't have any houses and they get
eaten by fish. Yeah. That's ridiculous.
Not that fucking smart. They're not that
smart. So they know how to open a jar.
Whoa. Fucking now can teach
a dog to open the jar,
close the lid behind you and
you're home free. God is not hard.
I'm a three year old can open a
fucking jar. Right. That's so stupid.
Think that they are super intelligent.
They have also ability to
communicate with their skin,
which I find incredibly fast.
Amazing to watch. That's just nuts.
The visual communication, they, they,
they used to think at one time that
was just camouflage that they were just
adapting to their environment,
which they also capable of doing it,
but they also somehow or another
communicate with each other by their skin,
by the way they look and they
think that that squid ink may be,
it serve two purposes. It may one,
try to ward off predators in some way,
create confusion and allowed to escape,
but also might be like eraser fluid. Like,
forget what I just said. That's all
bullshit. Let's just wipe that out. Yeah.
There's some interesting work done on,
on the octopus and Octopi commune.
Uh, I don't know if you've
ever seen videos of cuddle
fish hunting but using the
patterns in their body to
hypnotize their pray. But I,
I've got a book called EarthCorps fiction
book and the whole race in that book
is based on the cuddle fish. So all
of their communication is almost non.
There's almost no verbal,
it's all visual and it's the patterns
changing on their skin would just how they
talk to each other and how they hunt
as a pack. Wow. Yeah, it's pretty,
pretty sweet. It's pretty sweet. That's
so why I wonder how wolves communicate.
Like when wolves decided to
going to sneak up on somebody,
like if they do something,
like if they have a situation like wolves,
like they'll corner an animal.
Like they'll have like some,
some will go this and
others we'll wait for
him on the other end like this somehow
or another communicate with each other.
Well
that's,
that's probably of all the six we did
this and it worked so, but they are,
they are smart as shit and they
are capable of remembering. Okay.
You guys got do you guys got the rounder
roll? Make sure they don't blank out.
They don't flank out to the side.
Here's the guys pushing and then yeah,
these things have cascading
color on their body.
What do you think they do it with though?
I mean are they doing it with this when
they're talking about wolves and doing
it with smells or using pheromones,
like how would they communicate? They,
from what I know about it,
they're actually,
they teach the puppies and the young
ones how to do it, like teaching.
They're like,
you're going to go here or they
will follow the adult and they look.
It's a learned skill. It's
just like a pack of humans
hunting and they, they, they,
they're brought up like your role is this
and then as they become more dominant
in the pack, they changed their role
in the hunting pack. You've seen them,
I'm sure you've seen the video of the
chimpanzees organizing an armed party to
go after monkeys. No, I don't think
I've seen this so crazy. It's,
it's one of the weirdest videos.
And it was one of the first instances
where they were completely sure that
chimpanzees were not just vegetarians,
where they knew the chimpanzees
were not just carnivorous,
but they were eating primates.
And you've seen that Brian,
we ever showed that video?
I think so.
We'll show the video of the chimpanzee
eating a monkey cause it's, it's fucked.
Just wondering the team of two. Yes.
BBC from the BBC. Yeah. So they, um,
they have all these monkeys in the trees
and what they do is they send chimps
after them to chase him and they start,
you know,
like swinging on the trees and then on
the other end they have chimps waiting as
the monkeys tried to escape.
So they've heard them into this
area where these dominant chimps,
we'll be waiting and the chimps will,
uh, attack the monkeys in the trees,
but they, the corner them and
trap them. They have like,
they get him on the sides and they get
him in the front and they corral them
into an area where other chimps are
waiting. And then they grabbed him.
They figured that out like how did they
organize that? Do they talk about it?
How do they know?
How do I know there's going to be people
on the other end or chimps on the other
end waiting when I chased these
monkeys down, that's pretty advanced.
That's super advanced.
They've somehow or another figured out
a way to talk to each other and say,
look man, I want to eat a monkey.
You guys when to eat some lunch.
This is how we do it.
They hide in the trees.
We got to do is chase him
down there and Mike and Bob,
you guys will stand on the corners,
chase him this way and
then a Tommy at the end.
It's just going to gather them all up. I'm
going to eat. That's a killer question.
How do they communicate that?
That would take people like if a bunch
of random people were stranded on a
deserted island and they had
to figure out how to hunt,
it would take them until like they were
on the brink of starvation till they
figured that out. They'd be like, well,
let's go try and get some food. And,
but we took a long fucking time,
really strategies,
a trippy thought with that to me is not
knowing how long they've been exhibiting
this behavior.
That's exactly how they catch monkeys
and orangutans and chimpanzees.
So was somebody watching the humans
do this and go, that shit works great.
I don't think so, but it might because
it's like we have a lot of evidence
to them killing chimpanzees before and
they might literally a developed that
from watching how we do it to
them, which is fun. It's crazy.
Most likely though that they're just
smart and they figured you're smart if you
got that video.
Yeah. A Jimmy just told me that, uh,
that's the video that every time we played
that they yank. I saw youtube though.
Oh really?
What we could show grape ape and a monkey
that's very realistic. They Yank
us off youtube just for that. Yeah.
That was a BBC One fucking BBC.
It's the Internet bitch.
You're never going to win. You're
never gonna beat the Internet. But, um,
the mean the way they treat monkeys
and the way we treat whales,
the way we treat killer whales,
it,
it really is a perplexing question.
Like what will the next thing,
how will that treat us if there is an
artificial artificial intelligence,
super genius robot that becomes some
sort of a synthetic organic thing that's
almost indistinguishable from
humans but infinitely smarter?
How is it going to deal with us?
You know,
is it going to deal with us the way
we deal with the chimps or the way the
chimps did with the monkeys are the way
we deal with the dolphins or the way the
killer whales deal with the dolphins?
How's it going to deal with,
they're not setting a very good precedent.
Why would he want to keep us
around and make us be lazy, Shitty,
unproductive workers that are really
angry that our robot overlords have taken
over? Or there's just the basic
problem with work. We're too smart.
Would you want to keep some if the,
if we had monkeys in the La area and
they walked around with switchblades and
guns and every now and then we'd
start killing people. He'd be like,
we gotta get rid of those monkeys.
And you know,
this is a funny conversation because
whenever you have this conversation about
artificial intelligence,
you're going to get a lot of naysayers
and a lot of people that claim that they
know what's going to happen. Like,
listen, that's not going to happen.
We would never allow it. We would
never engineer that. We would never,
I get ya, I get ya.
However, it might have been,
that guy would never allow it.
That guy, whenever engineering,
there's always somebody out there who's
just either for the money or it's like,
God, I wonder if I can do that. That's
the driving force behind discoveries.
I wonder if I can make that happen. And
this insatiable need to push technology.
Just insatiable.
The drive that people have to to
continue to innovate is spectacular.
Every day there's some new
goddamn hundred 10 inch TV.
That's 44 k Michael Bay. Yeah. What
happened with that Michael Bay was doing,
he was doing a presentation and
the prompter fail and he locked up.
It is he, he couldn't even
just wing it like he could eat.
Like all he had to do is talk
about what he does as a director.
Like I make movies and he tried to do it,
but then he stopped and then
the guy's like, you know,
why don't we just talk about these
new TVs? You know, these curved TVs?
And he could have just said, yeah,
they look beautiful or something,
but instead he starts mumbling and
then just wa and goes, excuse me,
it's on stage. Oh, so he bombed.
He got panicky and happens.
Happens to the best of us.
I don't want to watch some really creepy.
That's all good to see.
It's like,
it's like watching a really bad
comedian right before you go on stage.
Like if someone's up there just bombing
and then you have to go on stage.
You don't think could be funny.
It's dangerous for you if you
get a sniff of his craziness.
Some guys like t petrified,
you might think of that.
That might like enter into your head.
It's like a single cell and start
dividing like a little virus,
a little mental virus. Very dangerous.
That can take your performance down.
Most likely. No, but I don't like
the feeling. I don't like watching.
Like I don't like watching people
bomb. It's, it feels gross. Yeah,
I know what it feels like. I've
got to get out of there. You know?
I don't think it's very hard to go
on after. This is why I think it's a,
it might actually be affecting people
and this is also why I think people enjoy
inspiration. I think when you
see someone who's really bad,
you really don't think that
anything's good. You think
like, this is what life is.
Life is like really terrible.
Life is terrible comedy.
Someone's bombing on
stage and on the opposite,
when you see something really spectacular,
it raises your standards for
things that you could accomplish,
things that you could be excited to
see it. It raises your standards.
If you go to see Avatar, so some
spectacular movie, it's, you leave that,
you would think it would
be the inverse of that. Oh,
I want to follow the guy who bond.
Even if I phone it in,
I'm going to do well and I don't want to
follow avatar because it's spectacular
and I'm going to look for ha. Well,
some people do have that, that mindset.
Some people have this really ultra
competitive mindset and they, uh,
like a lot of comics like to bring
terrible comedians with them on the road.
They bring guys who just really
shouldn't even be going on stage.
And the comic is like really pretty good.
So it'd be like this death show for 20
minutes and then the comment comes in
like a hero and everybody's
super excited to see him.
I've seen that happen on numerous
occasions, but that's famine mentality,
that famine mentality,
that there's not enough for everybody,
that the famine mentality that,
you know,
you have to get all the accolades and
anybody that's threatening whatsoever to
your, you know, your talents,
your abilities. So it should
be just minimalized. Hmm.
You know, that's a, that's a
dangerous mindset to have in a,
especially in the world of
comedy. No, but I think, uh,
if you instead choose to be
inspired by good performances,
then everything becomes inspirational.
It's not like everything's competitive.
Instead of it being competitive,
you get all the same juice that you would
get from the competitive aspect of it,
but you get it in a positive form. Instead
you're inspired and happy for people.
Success, happy for great movies, happy
for great music, happy for great comedy.
When you see great things inspired
by them, so everywhere around you,
you see inspiration instead of everywhere
around you. You seeing competition,
people doing better than you,
something that diminishes your,
your idea of who you are as a person
because you don't measure up on paper to
Michael Bay or this guy or
that guy. Instead of that,
it's the opposite. You know,
the mentality is you're
constantly being inspired. Just a,
it's a matter of engineering
your thoughts. That's all.
It really got significant.
I've had, it's better now, but I've had
significant issues with other authors.
You know what? The people start
out, same time I did roughly
and have similar,
similar career arcs moving up.
And then they just catch lightening by
the tail for something and the next thing
you know, they're huge. And I'm like,
we're basically working equally.
Everybody's working their fingers to
the bone like every other profession.
Anybody who succeeds anywhere,
it's probably working their ass off.
And then you just watch them
blow up and you're like, that's,
that's difficult to
overcome. You're like, oh,
that guy got all the goodies that guy
got there first. Um, and you know,
hockey these for you? Oh yeah. Yeah.
And it's like you say, it's a lot,
a lot of it has been adjusting
the perspective. You have
to step back and say,
I'm still doing really well and I'm making
a lot of people really happy with my
stories and my books and I can
now aspire to get to that level.
So I have to write something better and
market it better and connect better and
finally get that out there.
Well,
I think sometimes it's just a matter
of people finding out about it.
It's really that simple. It's like
the product is there for a long time,
but there's so much product you walk into,
Barnes and noble,
start roaming through the fiction section,
find a bunch of authors you don't know
when you read the back of the book and
you see a few recommendations that
you probably respect too. I fuck it,
I'll take a chance.
But for the most part they're,
the choices are endless and new
books are coming out constantly.
It's difficult to get scenes difficult
to get discovered and that the,
the exposures is the biggest thing and
people hearing about what you do and then
maybe hearing two or three times for,
they're familiar with like this is my
second time in the show and the first time
we got a ton of new readers,
people are like, God,
that guy sounds pretty cool to me.
Check out his books and
we've got all these fans now.
Now in the second time maybe you get
more and you know all of that effort.
The next book's out,
it's called pandemic.
It's out January 21st and just trying
to get people exposed to it so that they
can say, that sounds like
my cup of tea or, yeah,
I don't think I'd be interested in that.
That's the real game.
It's not getting people to read
or forcing people to read it.
It's just a matter of if
nobody's ever heard of me,
they don't get the opportunity to make
that decision if my stuff is a is in
their alley or not.
Does that get in the way at all
of the creative process for you?
Is it like an unwanted annoyance,
like this extra thing of trying to
promote and trying to figure out how to
promote and then would it be easier for
you if you could get past that and get
to this like Stephen King point where any
oil you have to do is just write shit,
dude. You know, anybody getting to the
Anne Rice, Stephen King, Dean Koontz,
you know, uh, any of those
levels where they just flat out,
he doesn't have to worry about anymore.
Stephen King could give a crap about
marketing because that's all going to get
taken care of for him. And He's, he's
earned that and he's totally fine. Yeah.
But uh, so we do, yeah, we,
I put a lot of time in a marketing
and trying different things, um, to,
to get the word out and all of that.
Every minute I spent
doing that as a minute.
I'm not creating or refining a story.
Like one of the things we did
today was for all of the listeners,
remember that book I told you
about last time title fight,
which was the science fiction MMA.
We decided we're just going to give
that away to all your listeners through
January. If they go to our
website. I'm Scott sigler.com oh,
it's up on the screen, right? Who
was that? That was not a fighter. No,
that's the one you said you asked me
if I was writing gay porn last time.
That's right.
That looks like who smaller par Horez
there's a couple of guys that looked like
that, but mark, Mark Coleman used to
look like that to some extent. No,
he wasn't even that big.
He huge,
if anybody goes to that store and puts
that in their cart and then uses the code
death squad, they get that
ebook for free. Beautiful,
beautiful read on their computer.
They can read it on their tablet
and their kindle, etc. Awesome.
So these are the kinds of things that,
and it's not like,
you know the Stephen Kings in
the Joe Hill's don't still do,
or their people do that marketing
stuff for them. But yeah,
we have to do things like that to be like,
just like, I know if you read my shit,
I'm going to own you. It's
just that simple. Pull up
Mark Kerr, mark curves the only MMA
fighter that really looked like that.
They actually did a fascinating
documentary on mark courage. No,
I have the smashing machine. It's called
the smashing machine. It is fucking dark.
It's deep because mark was like super,
super open with them and they're like,
while he was filming this documentary,
they were doing this documentary
on this unstoppable MMA fighter.
This guy who was this wrestler
who was just destroying people.
He's built like a fucking
superhero super athlete,
taking people down and smash
them. No, that's when he's fat.
You've got to get him when he's young.
You got to get him when he's young.
Mark her huge.
Just find,
find an image of him when he was
just unbelievably huge. So anyway,
this documentary, they start doing this
documentary and along the lines, the,
it exposes his drug use and he's opened
when he shoots up right in front of
these people and they capture this guy
completely spiraling out of control.
They just come into the right moment
as they're filming this documentary and
catch this guy who was like one
of the best fighters in the world,
completely spiraling
on camera shooting up.
You got to just get a picture of him
when he was in his prime. There's a,
you know, there's some photos of him
like fighting in the UFC. Yeah, that's,
that's him. Holy Cow.
Oh, that doesn't work.
Look at the size of that
motherfucker that, I mean, that was,
that was when they were calling
them the smashing machine.
He was 265 pounds of American
muscle and Mexican supplements.
And he was some mashing people,
but along the way developed a,
an addiction too. I believe it was
opiates. I think it was shooting up.
Look out fucking big. He was,
dude, are you shitting me?
And did he just kind of take himself
out or did he get beat and go?
He started going down. I started getting
beat, you know, well he was doing drugs,
you know,
he's having like a real drug problem and
he was fighting while he was a addicted
to drugs. Okay. And then, yeah,
I think he eventually went and
became a car salesman. But the, um,
I think it's an important documentary.
It's an important,
not just from the point of view
of someone who, um, is, uh,
having a serious problem with drugs, but
it's all steroids. He had a, you know,
he's absolutely on massive
amounts of steroids. Yeah.
He was also fighting and MMA,
which is the thing about traumatic brain
injuries and punches and kicks it you
take,
it's like
sometimes the of damage can lead these
guys to be like really depressed and
suicidal and crazy if they
sustained too much damage,
if they're not really careful about it.
If they don't give themselves
enough time to recover,
they can get really depressed.
So here's this guy taking
shots to the head all the time,
taking morphine or heroin or whatever
the fuck is taking, you know?
And they caught him in this doc.
Perfect,
perfect timing for right
when it all fell apart.
They came in thinking he was the baddest
motherfucker on earth and they left
with this really in depth piece on a guy
whose life is being absorbed by drugs.
Drugs are just stealing his life, just
taking it in little pieces, you know?
And he wound checked that out.
He wound up fighting later in his
career like no steroids, no drugs,
completely different body looked
like a guy just stepped out of a bar.
It was really strange. How did he
do at the end? Is he still terrible?
It's getting destroyed. Oh Geez. Um,
pull up a picture of mark her fat.
I don't want, I liked the
guy. I'm not teasing him.
I mean this is just the reality
of who he was at the end.
Look at him. That's what he looked like
at the end. Wow. Yeah. Quite a difference.
Yeah. Oh, the before and
after. It was incredible and a,
I saw him fight a couple times live
when he was in that state and I saw him
fight live when he was the
destroyer. You know, it was shocking,
really shocking stuff. But
uh, you know, that world is
shocking. It's a crazy world.
The world with your body.
Do you think eventually they're
going to get to the point where,
cause usually guys are losing their three
of their last four of their last three
years and then they retire.
Is it going to get to a point
where you know you have,
so he's going to step in and be like,
yeah,
we're just going to go ahead
and make a decision for you all?
They certainly have. They've done
that in many fighters. Yeah. Yeah.
They've retired quite a few fighters.
Chocolate.
Dell is the most obvious example
because he was like one of the greatest
champions ever and Dana and him at very
good friends and at the end of Chuck's
career, Chuck asks for one more
fight and wonder if I rich Franklin.
He lost that fight and he's like,
that's it. We're good. That's it.
I got to step away.
And so he realized it was time.
The Arnold Arnold's 62
it look like that now.
He also is a training
for the Conan movies.
Kona King cone in finally.
Yes. Oh that's right.
You're a Robert Howard fan.
Yeah.
Can we talk about Robert Howard last
time when I don't. I don't think so,
but that,
that,
that was my goal ever of watching the
first two Conan movies and even red stone
back in the day.
I'm like,
I want to write king cone and I never
got to the point where I could talk to
anybody, have any contacts. I'm like,
that movie's got to get made cause it's
perfect. Now he's the perfect age for it.
It can be spectacular. Yeah.
Folks don't know that Robert E.
Howard made Conan in many different
areas. It wasn't just a young, virile,
powerful Conan.
He also made King Conan when Conan was
the king of scenarios is I think so.
W opponent. The Sumerian?
Yeah. Well he was the Samarian,
but I don't think he was a king of that.
I think he took over some new place.
I don't remember. I don't remember. Yeah,
they were great fucking books though.
Those, those books sort of in my mind,
like kind of defined my childhood.
I really got fast fascinated with
fantasy and that kind of shit. It was,
it was the Robert E. Howard books crawl,
was it called a conqueror? Conquer. Yeah.
That was so good. Yeah. Cyclops in
that movie. The movie was just, uh,
a shit version of the books. Really?
The books. Yeah. The movie is fine,
but it's probably dated now. If you've
probably watched it now, you'd hate it.
Well, at the moment, yeah, I don't, I
don't go back and watch some movies.
The movies,
the Scifi movies I loved,
and I was a kid with the exception of
like Predator and aliens just don't watch
them anymore. You can't ruins
everything. You really can't.
But Robert Howard created some amazing
Conan books that never really have been
captured correctly. They try, they did
a little bit better with the new Conan,
the new guy. Oh yeah, like I think the
new guy is, first of all. Yeah. Yeah.
Way More realistic. Way more like the
actual Qa. Like he's an enormous guy.
Like he's not billing a bodybuilder.
He's bill. Go to the new Conan guy,
Jason Momoa, who's, I've met a
minimum of UFC two very nice guy,
and he's fucking huge.
This kid is like six foot six.
It's just this perfect
specimen of manhood. He's
never gonna make it out alive.
He's gonna fuck so much that
he's going to die. There's,
there's no way he can avoid it.
If I was here like Jason Momoa,
he fucked himself to death to death.
He's six foot six and he's a
beautiful man and he's a movie star.
There was no way he doesn't have,
there's no way he gets it together.
Look at that it get the fuck out.
Get the fuck Outta here. Come on.
That kind of didn't,
I didn't watch the news because they
just didn't want the old one to be,
I didn't want them to sell a, the original
Coney, because I'm a giant fan of them.
They only sullied it
in like half the movie.
You could just cut out half
the movie and have that movie,
have no ending and like it was a
good effort. It was a good attempt.
I think ultimately what Kona and needs
and deserves is that guy is the perfect
Kona and he's a good actor. He
looks like a savage. Keep that,
keep him as the Kona and just get a
real writer who's a real fucking crazy
person who can come up with something
bad ass and follow the robbery Howard
script.
Follow what that guy and then do it
through the eyes of like a real visionary.
Get a real James Cameron type dude or
how about Martin Scorsese does Konan how
about you?
You have a movie where it's like a really
dark fantasy movie that plays out like
a real film instead of plays
out like some bullshit comic.
That's always the thing that's confused
the crap out of me with the marvel,
the crappy marvel movies
that made when I was a kid,
like why or the the old Spiderman TV
show when I was a little kid. I'm like,
I'm like,
when is he going to fight a super villain?
I don't give a shit if he's
stopping bank robbers and it was,
it never made any sense to me.
That's like comic books.
Tell these stories that
are massively popular.
Why don't you just tell that story?
Why do you think you have
to reinvent everything?
And the Kona and books
will be a similar thing.
Like this already entertained a large
percentage of the planet at one time.
It's not dated because there's no,
you know, 19th century technology.
It's tell the same frigging story.
Yeah.
Tell the story and now with the new
technology, the fucking monsters saying,
did you see the hobbit? No, I
haven't seen to have it yet. Oh yeah,
that dragon is worth seeing the
whole movie. Just to see that dragon.
That reminds me, that's what I
want it to. I haven't seen it,
but one of the funniest things ever is
when news reporters have to talk about
that movie because that,
that Smaug snuggled up
next it distillations of
[inaudible] and the [inaudible].
I want to tell you the sense that
since the law, speaking of monsters,
because we're closing in on
the option for nocturnal,
one of my books that's going to be done
by Lloyd 11 as a TV show and he's the
guy that did Hellboy and
Hellboy two fucking dude knows,
knows his monsters like nobody's
business, but amazing. Congratulations.
Thank you. But this happened
because of your show. We had, uh,
one of your listeners name is
Nikki Monta, my gosh. Darn it.
[inaudible] is that right
now? Yeah. Nicky Ahmond,
she works for a alumnae,
Lucy Steele.
I who's an agent at the paradigm agency
in New York. So I was on your show.
Mickey heard it and said, wow, that
nocturnal sounds really cool and reads it,
and then it goes, goes to her boss
and says, I think this is significant.
You need to read it. Her boss reads it.
Lucy reads it. Contacted my print agent.
We were done with our current
film agent at the time.
We'd worked together five years. Great
Guy, but we didn't make anything happen.
So time to change something.
So we talked, Lucy,
Lucy takes over and now we're almost
not only almost closed on nocturnal,
but then the the guys,
the people who make a
justified an elementary are
closing and an option for the
infected series, which pandemic is
the last book. That's incredible.
This lady's kicking ass and it came
because of Niki listening to your show.
That's incredible. Cut to three years
from now. It's like God's on coke
laying in his mansion and his
underwear doing a new red.
Sonja remake was Miley
Cyrus? Yes. Smashing. Look,
a champagne bottle on the ground
because there's nothing left.
There's my fucking drank.
So just a quick thank you out to Nikki
if she's listening to this because just
one person listening to it,
running up the tree as a, you know,
change a lot of things for us.
That's all it takes, right? I mean,
like I said, your product is amazing.
I've gotten nothing but positive
responses from people that read your book.
After that, you came on the
podcast for some time. Do you just,
people need to find out about
it. So now they go. Good.
That's going to be crazy man.
Well if we get, you know,
and of course either one of
the TV shows could not happen,
which is how things work in Hollywood.
But if he gets super rich,
you're going to buy a ball or spot in
San Francisco. Oh yeah. You kidding?
Well I don't hold block.
I don't know about San Francisco,
but if you get super rich you could
buy basically Roman small country in
Michigan and call it Detroit
cause it's already named.
He could buy the whole thing.
But again,
you'd have to be in Detroit
and be cold as hell. Yeah.
All their castles built in the
middle of San Francisco. You know,
you're pretty sweet, you know, like you've
ever been to Stephen King's place? No.
Main nope. When I used to
work in main ways to stand up,
we used to do a Gig in Bangor and you
couldn't go to Bangor without driving by
Stephen King's house. He had to to know
that's where Stephen King labs. Right,
right, right. Cause like he had
this giant cast doubt on mark.
Mark Twain's will house and
he by Mark Twain Says Daddy,
I think that's smart planes house. I'm
not sure about Mark Twain lived in Maine.
I could be wrong. I, it's what I've
heard. But continuing continue. Well, um,
he has like,
you can tell it's his house.
He has this a rod iron fence outside of
his house and he's like gargoyles and
shit on it. Oh sweet. Pretty
obvious to anybody comes by.
Well it's a big house too. It's, you know,
but it's not ridiculous. Like he doesn't,
he doesn't have like a castle.
He lives in a nice big house and he
doesn't have any seven rooms or something
like that. Not really. I mean it's a
very nice house, but it's nothing crazy.
Like I guess that's how
he fits in up there.
Cause you know Bangor is a fairly modest
environment and for fairly modest city.
That's his house. Yeah. Nice.
So you drive by and you see this
metal fence with the gargoyles on it.
See if he can get a photo
of the, the, the alliance,
I wonder about that is he's got some
crazy fans and that's 20 feet from the
sidewalk to the front door.
So you wonder if Steve,
some of Stephen King's money goes to,
there's a couple of dudes lurking around
that property at all times. There's,
you know, if you jumped that fence,
that's your ass. I would have,
I would have for sure evil
dogs everywhere. Everywhere.
I would hire ninjas to just practice
on people. Come up with a fence,
dudes with swords. I wouldn't fuck
around guys on the roof. See the roof,
crossbows silence.
Just poison Arrow Samurai in the front
porch just announced that this is what's
going to happen to you. That's what
the fuck I'm talking about. Yeah,
but it devil Zombie. Samurais but he
would have, that'd be a, actually,
that's the name of my next
book is Samurai Hooker. Yeah.
Scott Sigler. Cause you need that heart
of gold in there to sell the book, right?
Yeah. You can't just have a devil's
Zombie Samurai. Who am I rooting for it?
They're all cunts. You have
a country, country, country.
If you have it, you know.
Harte gold extra x hooker. Yeah.
Now you're, now you're talking,
there's a good story there.
She did it because her dad
had cancer. How about that?
That's why she did it. She needed money.
Her Dad is, games are against that.
Camera it against Zombie. Plus.
What's really wrong with hookers?
Let's stop. Let's leave them
alone. Yes, yes. No, I have
no problem with this issue.
Well there it is. So that's how uh, the
Scott Sigler legend was launched. Yes.
And apparently you already know how it's
going to end with the Zombie Samurai
Hooker and a smash champagne bottle
and a baller pan and San Francisco.
It could end like that or the artificially
intelligent robots could take over
first. And we have high, if I
get rich, the first thing to do,
he is investing in Google
so they don't kill me. Yeah.
And concrete because the robots are
going to eat concrete. Remember? Okay,
thank you. Okay, great. Building a lot
of concrete around here you go boys.
I'll be over here. I wonder if it would
be, I mean Google by all, if you know,
you know,
you look at what they've done,
they don't seem to have done anything
evil. They seem to be very conscientious,
very rich and wealthy,
but also very conscientious.
You always hear about how great their
campuses and how people will work there.
Really enjoy the environment.
Like this is a,
there's a guy works at Google who's a guy,
but in the daytime he decided he wants
to be a woman. So he shows up at work,
dressed as a woman and changes at
the end of the day and goes home
and he's a man again and they,
so they changed his name at work.
They totally accepted it.
And the Guy Guy's married and has kids
and he's a wife. You know he's at,
he has a wife and when he gets
home he becomes a man again,
but while he's at work, he decided that he
wants to be a woman. They're like, okay.
It doesn't surprise
from what I know of Google,
that doesn't surprise me. Like,
do you still get your work?
Yeah, we could give a shit. I
don't care. I think it's good.
As long as he's not crazy, it doesn't
even fucking dwell on it. It's weird.
Secret world of men who dress like
dolls and think that's the same story.
That's equally creepy. That
one Google might be, yeah,
we're going to have to have a meeting
about this robot mass dressing up like the
doll is distracting, so let's
have, let's have a meeting. Yeah.
That's way creepier dressing up
like a woman. It's like, okay.
Guess you wanted to know, you know?
Have you ever had the fantasy?
What would you do if you
could be a woman for a day?
Apparently work at Google.
Yeah.
That's what you can do a
little and put a mask on or be,
it would be a fake robot.
People are fucking weird man. The
things that people enjoy, you know,
whatever floats hour long. As long
as getting hurt. Exactly. Yeah.
As long as you're not being an asshole.
When you start writing a book, do you,
do you like sit down and it's like say,
okay,
I want to figure out something to write
about or do you just have like a flash
of inspiration and then you know,
record it,
write it down and then take off with it?
Like how do you, how do you start a buck?
I, mine is much is more
structured, so the,
the ones I write for random house,
um,
they're thrillers with a lot
of horror and Psi Phi in them.
But the thriller structure is,
you know,
things are planned out to get to this
really crazy over the top ending.
So a lot of times I'll have the concept,
then I'll try and work through a loose
structure to come up with an ending
that's going to be just
balls out spectacular.
And then sort of work backwards from
there. So if I do that correctly,
if I reverse outline it correctly
by the time and go from,
this is insane,
I would never buy into this too.
This is a guy having a cup of coffee
at his kitchen table in the morning.
It feels like a seamless transition.
You never noticed that your grant,
I'm gradually upping the level of madness
to get to that crazy end and you're
just fully hooked and believing every
moment of it. So it's mostly structured.
I don't think I,
I don't think I have an immediate just
right and then let it go and see where
the story goes cause I need to have,
you know,
30 or 40 threads that all
funneled towards that last ending.
Even pandemic,
which is the third book in a series.
It goes infected than
contagious. Then pandemic. Um,
each of those three books has a
relatively calm beginning and, uh,
earth shattering end.
But they are complete story unto
themselves simply because I don't,
I don't believe in extorting
fans out of their money.
You get a full story for this book.
If you don't want to read the next book,
you don't have to buy that to see what
happens at the end of the first bucket.
I don't just cut it in half.
So for pandemic it was,
it's largely the end of pandemics.
Just ape shit crazy.
It's the whole world screwed. And you
had to come up with, how do I do this
much damage and then
work it back from there.
So it all feels like it
flows together naturally.
When you talked to other authors,
is there like several different schools
of thought as far as creating a story?
Cause I know Stephen King Oil,
which I found really fascinating.
His book on writing. Did you read it? Yep.
Really like a Bible. It's great. Really,
really good book.
Well,
what I found fascinating is that he
doesn't have a structure at all. Nope.
He just starts riding. I heard
an interview with um, uh,
a writer named Joe Abercrombie,
interviewed George Rr
Martin, the game of Thrones,
author Joe Abercrombie's stuff you
like fantasies ridiculously good.
And of course George Rr Martin's
game of Thrones. And George R.
Martin described it.
I don't know if he came up with this,
but this is where I heard it.
He said there's two kinds of writers.
There's the Gardner and there's
the architect, and he's a gardener.
And Stephen King,
our Gardner,
where they put the seed in the
ground and they cultivate it.
Then they just let it grow wherever
it grows. I like this, fine.
I'm gonna follow this fine. I liked
this flower would follow this flower,
whereas the architect, which is more like,
you know, Tom Clancy or my stories, you,
you'd blueprint and then you build the
foundation. Then you build a framework,
and then gradually, okay, now
we're gonna put in dry electrical.
Now we're going to put in plumbing,
now we're going to put it in dry wall,
and now we're going to finish it.
Now we're going to paint it.
You know what it's going to
look like before it's done.
But there's all the work
to make it complete.
So those are the two kinds of
writers and king's definitely in the,
in the Gardner. Righty. He just lets
us shit roll. That's fascinating. Um,
have you ever tried to do it that way or
do you enjoy the structure aspect of it?
Like have you thought about doing it
different ways? I mostly enjoy the,
the tetris game of getting
it all to come out.
And it's really a love hate relationship
because if you're as anal retentive
about like this has to,
you have to feel closure at the end of
this book and a half to tie up all the
threads when you do that, as you're
working through some of the characters,
change who they are and all
of a sudden you're like, okay,
now this guy would never do this thing.
He would never go into the haunted
house alone. He just wouldn't do it.
And then you got to say, I,
how do I get around that?
And usually break stuff so you have to
tear the building down and go back and
build it up all over again. And when I
do that, uh, with the book nocturnal,
I was just talking about my business
partner. Uh, a Kovacs had to deal with me.
I was,
I was miserable for like six months
cause I wrote three full dress and at the
end of every full draft I'm like,
this just, this doesn't work.
This is not believable. I could not get
through this book and go, that's what,
that's what would happen.
So I had to rip it all down and start
over and move all the parts round again.
And I never thought I would get, I
was like, I'll never get this right.
This will never work out with
this concept that I have.
And I finally got it to work with
some great help from Julian Puffy,
who's my editor at random house. We
finally got it figured out, but it was,
I was freaking miserable.
So I would like,
eventually I want to get to the
gardener face. I just, wherever it goes,
it doesn't matter.
Let's just have fun.
Do you get mad when you read a book that's
kind of Piss poor from an author that
you really respect? Totally. Yeah.
That's a foot like there's so many authors
in so many books right now. I am this.
Why work so hard to make my stuff so
tight and so refined? It's very admirable.
I like how you approach it.
Well it's,
I look at it from the
customer's point of view.
If you drop 24 bucks on own book
and you can tell I phoned it in,
you're not coming back
cause I'm not coming back.
If I read your book and I'm like,
this is the lace,
yours being so lazy and you took my
money and you didn't work for it,
I'll never read that author again.
Or you've, you've completed the work.
It's not that anybody who's being lazy,
but sometimes there's a puzzle that people
just don't have the effort to solve,
but it's not that they're not
working hard, they just didn't,
they didn't complete it or they're under
deadline and now I understand more.
Like when I was younger I was much more
adamant like fuck you for taking my
money. You Lazy Bastard. Now I
understand like, yeah, there's a,
there's an ax at the
back of your neck saying,
we've got to get this
book to press right now.
If you want to get it out by December.
Yeah, for Christmas. You have to. Yeah.
So that's what people go through a lot.
When you think,
when you think you've read a shotty work,
a lot of times it's,
they just ran out of time.
They didn't have time to do it.
I think it's very cool though
that you think like that.
I think it's very cool that
you think about the, uh,
the audience and the people buying.
I think that's super important.
It adds an element of a,
you have a connection with
them. You're not above them,
you're not beyond them. You're
part of them. They need them.
You appreciate them and then you
respect them as you're writing.
You consider them.
I think that's big it in this,
maybe this is from being a big
reader before the ebooks set,
but it wasn't that long ago,
you know,
to to buy the new Stephen King Book for
seven 95 and paperback seven 95 was a
chunk of money. You're like, okay,
I want this and I'm buying
this and better be good.
And then not Stephen King but somebody
else. You buy a book and you're like,
I didn't get my money's worth
and I worked hard for that money.
I've never forgot what that feels like.
And even though I'd still
give all my stuff away,
everything you can get on my website,
it's [inaudible] dot com serialized
books for free or@patiobooks.com and
everything I've published, we give away
for free as a serialized audio book.
We run advertising against it and we
listen to the ad at the beginning of the
show, just like your show. Then
you get 30 40 minutes an episode.
You don't have to pay for anything and
let's do it all you want. It's brilliant.
Lot of people, a lot of people can't
afford, they flat out can't afford books,
but they want their story. So that's
how they get it. So we do it that way.
And then if you actually buy the book,
my goal is always you would have paid
twice what you paid for it and you're
still happy. That's beautiful, man.
That's a great way of looking at things.
I love the fact that you give everything
away for free to put some ads on it.
Who gives a shit, you know? As
long as it doesn't interrupt,
interrupt the flow of the book. Right?
Was just like this, this podcast.
We never do an ad inside the podcast,
but don't want to interrupt
the flow of the conversation.
But I think giving people something for
free is important because it's nice,
it's nice to do.
It's a nice,
it makes people feel good that they
can get your good stuff for free.
They can go to Scott sigler.com they
could start downloading your audio books,
get hooked, have many, many, many more
hours of entertainment for fucking free.
And then we knew stuff comes out. They
want to support you. Yup, exactly.
That's organic and a lot of, a lot
of times what happens is people have,
a lot of people have money to spend
on entertainment and they don't mind
spending that money on entertainment if
they know they're going to get something
good.
What pisses people off is a spend their
money and then on something and then
find out that they don't
actually like the product.
So if I give these stories away,
you know,
that's my competitive
advantage over Stephen King.
If you go into a bookstore and
see Scott Sigler and Stephen King,
and you've never heard of me,
you're gonna by Stephen
King because a proven brand,
he's a proven storyteller.
But if you go to the bookstore in Stephen
King's 24 95 and Scott's hagglers free,
maybe I'll try this first,
then go get the Stephen King.
Now I've got a chance for
people to try out my stuff,
and if they listened to a couple of
books and they know what they're getting
from then on, then they,
they buy everything that
comes out today. It comes up.
Yeah. And you, you miss the viral aspect
when you charge people for things like,
um, do you know, uh, the,
there's La has a radio team. Uh,
it used to be frosty Heidi and frank,
and now it's just Heidi and frank.
Really Nice folks. Very, very fun people.
I've done their show a couple times and
they were on the radio and they went
from the radio to doing a podcast,
but they,
they were making their money
by charging for the podcast.
And so they had a good piece of change.
It was coming in every month,
but they couldn't grow.
They couldn't grow because no one can
find out about them because it just
doesn't, people don't, when you go,
hey, there's this team, you know,
Mike and fucking pissed face, and
they, uh, they have an awesome podcast,
but it costs two bucks. Trust
me. It's worth it. You're
like, how good could it be?
I can go download Adam Carolla.
I'll go download Joey Diaz.
Why would I bother spending two bucks
or something that I can get for free?
That's where it gets weird when
there's just too much. The Internet,
it's gotta be free. Everything's
gotta be free. If it's not free,
it's not going to work.
It's just there's too much that it's free.
That's too many options. Like you've got
to find another way to monetize things.
He can't do it. The simple
like knucklehead way of
charging that really hasn't,
I don't know anybody who's still doing
that or anybody who succeeded at charging
for their podcasts. They do.
No, they do very well. Which
I do is, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Dan Carlin makes a good
chunk of change out. He'll,
he'll get angry with me and yeah.
Well I barely make his podcast should,
his podcast is very different because uh,
like your audio books,
it's more like audio books on history,
but very dramatic and amazing flare to
me really gets you excited about learning
about history.
But he charges for like the,
he gives you the first 50
for free to get you hooked.
And then if you want to get into the,
the databases,
once you really get addicted and you've
been nothing but Dan Carlin for two
months, you run out and then
you're like, what the fuck?
And then he started paying money. Well
that, that's, that's perfectly good.
You know? Yeah, I know what you're paying
for at that point. People like Ah, that's,
that's totally worth a dollar an episode.
I know I'm gonna get my money's worth.
And then they don't give a shit.
That's the same thing that
happens with Nice staff.
Like once they know
what they're gonna get,
they are perfectly fine paying
whatever comes out. Well you know what,
it'll change it.
If everything became like Amazon one click
where you just like your computer has
all your credit card information
and then if you want something,
you just click on it and you go Amazon
one click because the Amazon one click
would be only be slightly more
difficult than just clicking on it and
downloading it slightly more difficult
cause you gotta pay a dollar.
It's just where the dollar. Okay.
Let's see if it's worth a dollar click,
it'd be pretty fucking easy to do.
But if you want to actually buy it,
like you gotta go and entering
credit card information,
get a pay pal account like this.
A lot of fucking steps that
you're just not going to do.
You're just going to change the tab
and go to another website and you know,
go download the Nerdist or something
like that. Cause it's free. It's hard.
It's hard to sell people
on buying something.
But that just means that people are
like people looking at it from the wrong
lens, you know there's a way to monetize
it and I think your way is the smartest.
Give him as much free content
as possible. Then they go, wow,
this guy's fucking talented and
then they want to support you. Yeah.
And there's a lot of, you know it's, I,
it's putting there the
decision in their hands. You,
the customer know what you want to spend
your money on and we honestly don't
give a shit if they just keep downloading
all of our books for free and never
pay for anything.
That's fine.
Cause at the very least they're going to
go to work or they're going to talk to
their friends, go, oh my God,
he should this crazy growth story
heard called infected. It's nuts.
This guy stabbing himself with a
fork for like five pages. It's nuts.
And then eventually somebody they're
talking to is going to go check it out or
just go by the book. So it's
not, you know, it's, it's one
we're, we're, we're, we're,
our goal is we entertain people. That's
what we do. We take you out of your world,
bring you into ours, take, get rid of
all your stress for a little while.
That's what we do for a living.
Some people want to do that for free.
Some people will pay for it.
And even the people get it for free.
You're going to go out.
If we're good enough at our jobs,
they're going to go out and talk to
their friends about it and we're going to
wind up getting that word of
mouth exposure. But we're big on,
we've got a giant chip on our
shoulder. We're like, ah, that's,
I work so hard to make my stuff so good
that I can give it to you for free.
You're still going to
give me money for it.
That's a great way of looking at it too.
You know what's cool about that?
It's just,
it's,
it's cool to think that you're also
getting by giving it away for free,
you're getting that
word of mouth exposure,
which he would be willing to pay
a lot of money for that. Yeah.
I can't compete against the Stephen King.
No one's put that kind of marketing money
behind me in it and we know that this
is a way for us to go out and get,
get new fans and get people to try us out.
Yeah. He's like royalty at
this point. He's like, God,
like it's aimed more at this point
and super fucking prolifically up.
Jesus Christ makes you feel like such
a lazy fuck when you see that guy just
churning bad ass book after Badass Book.
Yeah.
It would be one thing if he was totally
phoning it in, but he's not like,
people love these new books. Then the
new books that he's been coming out with,
there's still bad. I just
read doctor sleep, you know,
the SQL to the shining and uh, yeah,
Swahili. Yeah. Even heard of this.
This is fucking excellent.
It's really good. Whoa.
And then how long ago did you
put that in? Oh, it was only,
I'm going to say it's hard, honestly,
it's hard to tell them he's,
he's already got to 800 page
novels coming down the pipe,
but I'm going to guess it was
about three or four months ago.
And it is the Danny Torrence,
the little kid from the shining who's
now chronologically this is like the same
money or so now he's in his forties,
early forties I think.
And then he gets into a whole
new perplexing situation,
but book opens up with him,
him hitting rock bottom as an alcoholic.
Like it's rough. It's a rough read,
spoiler alert. Yeah, no, you go.
But it goes to some pretty nutty areas,
so yeah.
But he's prolific and he got what
he down does down to a science.
Did you read it? Yeah. Did you enjoy
it as much as the original shining? No,
I didn't. No, I didn't. And
that's partially because
now that he's at such a royalty level,
if he doesn't want to edit something, he
doesn't have to. And it's the same thing.
It's the same place George Rr Martin is,
I'm not at that area.
I can go up my publisher and say, Yep,
800 page novel. They'll say, great,
bring come back when it's 500 pages
and there's no way around it. You know,
you've got to go through and refine that.
And my editor is helping me make the
story better and better. Stephen King,
why is he going to listen to
anybody? Honestly, at this point,
and people come back and there's some,
you know, 25 year old interns like Nia.
I know, I think this movement to knee
is too long and he's a shorten up.
He's like, I'm Stephen King.
I think I know what I'm
doing. So the books now have,
they don't move quite as fast as they
used to move. That's interesting. So yeah.
So you credit the,
the editors with helping you
with me. Absolutely. I'm a long winded,
I'm a long winded motherfucker. Right.
If you gave me my druthers,
every book would be 1500 pages.
You would need a wheelbarrow to carry
that thing around if it wasn't for the
editors. And you know, the, the people
I work with, like my business partner,
but the books would be
just astronomically long.
So what kind of relationship is that?
That's an interesting relationship
with them. I hate them.
Uh, I'm bitching about one of the other
and the other to the other all the time.
You need them both. Yeah. Yeah. Well
I stomp around the office a lot. Uh,
you know, I've got some kettle bells in
the office like God damn, sons of bitches,
you know, and just and get
mad and uh, uh, but it's,
it's worked in a good relationship
and um, I hate to admit it, but I,
I bitch a lot during this process because
I get so frustrated because I want it
to be good.
I so badly want it to be perfect and I
want people to read it and walk away.
Like, holy crap, that's
the best book I ever read.
That's what I'm after every time. So
when the editors coming back going, yeah,
this isn't working.
And I'm like,
I've put eight months of work into that
thing that you just want to get rid of,
he's won. Beat the shit out of him.
Right. I just want to beat the shit out.
But they're right. They, the
ultimately they wind up being right.
Well when you stop listening, you know,
your fiction becomes something else.
Like [inaudible] you know,
the process where he was.
Everything he puts out makes 250 million
at some point he stops listening to the
people around them. Like, yeah, I
don't think the village is working out.
Maybe we should tweak this. And he's
like, it's tying that back channel. Yeah.
They don't ever see planes he doesn't have
to listen to anymore. Exactly. Exactly.
Yeah. So, so I still,
I still listen and it's not easy cause
they got a bit of an ego with the fiction,
but eventually these people break
me down and uh, and we make,
we make a more refined,
better story.
That's very honest of you. It's a
very honest in that, in that approach.
And I think that's one of the reasons why
you're so prolific and successful with
your writing is that you have that
ability to look at yourself and the entire
situation objectively. It's very difficult
to do for a creative person. Yeah.
A lot of creative people are
really bad at taking criticism.
I'm not good at it, but uh, the, the two,
the three primary people involved
in the process, my business partner,
my agent and my editor, it's um,
you know, I, I trust these people.
They're successful at what they do.
And at some point when they're telling
you something that is directly opposite
of what you think, you still
have to sit down and go. Like,
I'm going to evaluate what
you're saying on own merits.
And it's not like every time I change it,
I are there. Their stuff, I'll be like,
I'm fine. Don't fuckin publish the book
if you don't want that in there. Right.
I don't give a shit. Yeah. Like
if that doesn't go in the book,
you don't get the book. So
there's, there's debate.
It's not as simple as you just bring it
to them and then they say this is too
long and you shorten it up. You
sometimes go, no, it's not. So,
so you stand your ground occasionally.
Yep.
How do you know when to stand your ground?
There's just,
there's certain things where,
um,
as a storyteller you might not be able
to put into words the impact this moment
we'll have, but you know, in
your subconscious kind of,
you know that structurally it's going
to impact this point, this point,
this point and then the ending.
And then if you don't have this moment
that the editor doesn't really, he's like,
why, who cares what he had for breakfast
for example? It doesn't matter. Like, yes,
but that when,
when they get to the end and see that
breakfast food again at the end of the
book,
it's going to tie everything together
and it's going to give the reader this
sense of completeness in his, her whole
soul and like there'll be satisfied,
more satisfied with a book.
So there are things that I can't really
explain or I'll try to explain and
they're not listening.
But eventually I'm just like,
I know this works and that's got to go
in there and that's just the end of the
story. But then a part of the give
and take is, you know, it's it,
there's some quid pro quo and, and
I've had mad at her come back. Okay,
you can keep that, but if you keep
that, you got to give up this. Wow.
And he'll set it up in that like, and then
I'll, and then I'll just, I get furious.
This shit. Do you think you'll
ever get rid of him? Uh,
well then do you think you'll ever
be like, look, let's say rich,
I got this with the technology of ebooks.
Couldn't you just take like those chunks?
Like it's this huge chunks that they tell
you to take out and make it like kind
of like a director's cut. Like, Hey, you
buy an ebook and I'm also giving you this,
like the whole thing.
I worked on this storyline that they told
me to cut out what we did that with my
book ancestor, we had the final book
from Crown, which is random house.
And then there was like 50 pages
they cut out at the beginning,
like you don't need all that.
The story starts here in the general
thumb is you want to start as far into the
story as you possibly can.
But then I took those 50 pages and record
them as a podcast and give them their
radio. So it's kind of kind of the same
thing. But this is the last pandemics,
the last book I'm doing with Random
House and my agents taking new book out
called Flyer as of like today,
literally today, starting to,
to pitch it so we wind up
with random house again,
I may have the same guy or it
may wind up with somebody else.
I've been super lucky and that I've had
the same hardworking editor for all five
bucks, which from what I've told is
almost never happens to anybody. Seven,
the same guy.
So now he knows what I'm going for and
he knows my style and he knows how to
manage me to some regard and he knows
when to ignore me when I'm calling him
names and stuff like that. So it's been
an awesome, awesome experience with him.
So you have an editor, you have an
agent that also reads it as well.
How many different people read it
before you had basically three?
Basically three. Uh, my business partner
tends to read everything first, um,
and uh, and, and take her feedback.
She has less feedback than the editor,
but the feedback she brings
back is more significant. Uh,
so I'll pay attention to that.
And then the agent usually only manages
the first 80 pages. Got Crazy add.
And I'm like,
do you have to read the whole book?
If you want to be part of the process,
you've got to read the whole book.
I promise I'm going to
read the whole book.
Then like the last five
drafts is that first 80 pages.
That's all he gets through.
If you want to be one of those
wheeler dealer type agents,
you've got to have that sort of mentality.
He's very, very, he's
very good at what he does.
But we'll all, he cares about us. He knows
if I get this much of the book set up,
he knows the sales process. Right.
If you buy in the first 50 pages,
he can sell the book,
then your editors can fix the rest of it.
So he's not that invested in
the full length of the book.
And then the real work is done with a,
with Julie and the guy over at,
at Crown Random House who reads, not
only is he read it all the way through,
he's reading it all the way through five
times and having to pay close attention
like we're talking like 500 page books.
Wow.
He needs to pay super close attention
every time and I could not do his job at
all.
Now when you structure your stories,
do you use a software program to use
index cards on a, a bulletin board?
Like how do you set up where you're moving
all your pieces in your tetris game?
I used to things we do use,
I got a uh,
magnetic whiteboard in the office and
write on the index cards and put them all
up with that. And sometimes, you
know, strings between the cards,
that kind of thing. That's the
general getting it all down the flow.
And then I use a program called scrivener,
which people can use for Mac or PC.
And it's basically the same thing.
It's little index cards in the
computer and there's an index card that
represents a document. Each document
is a chapter, but it's great.
It's better than Microsoft
word because Microsoft word,
once you get past a hundred pages,
200 pages,
you're copying big chunks and moving
around and it becomes a nightmare cause
you're gonna screw something up.
But Scribner,
he just grabbed this icon
and drag it before this icon.
It rearranges everything.
So I've gotten pretty adept at
using that a highly recommend it.
It's great for scatterbrain
to keep everything flowing.
And then a lot of times it'll just be,
you know,
I get overwhelmed with the screen and
everything going on and I'll just pull out
the three by five index cards and
start writing everything down again,
bullet points and those put them up on
the board and go through it that way.
So you like to do it digitally,
like to do it manually.
You like to just mix it up and constantly
keep doing it in a different way that
keeps your brain moving?
Yeah, it, what I find is
when you get stuck there,
there's a couple of different things.
Number one,
if you're just staring at
that screen and you're stuck,
just getting your hands involved
in a pen. And I, you know,
like just an ink pen and paper is a
tactile experience is different experience
at activates different parts of your
brain sometimes can like, oh now I get it,
now I see what I was stuck on.
So that's part of it.
And other parts of it is either,
there's only so much screen real estate,
so you can only see so many things
at one time. If you really stuck,
you pull back, right? All these index
cards, you put it up in this, you know,
four foot by five foot whiteboard and
you kind of look at everything that can
spring your brain free at times too. So
it's largely, it's grabbing whatever's,
if I get stuck in one area,
I'll start going to other areas and um,
when I get really
overwhelmed, frustrated, I am
more comfortable slipping back into, you
know, the eight year old version of me,
which is a little piece of paper and some
notes or an index card and go back and
just ride it out till it all
kind of flows onto the page.
So as long as the process
is just continuing over and
over and over again. Yeah,
that's a scrivener. Yup. Yeah,
I use that for jokes I use.
Yeah I use it. I use a couple
of different things. One,
I use a real chalkboard or
real a corkboard rather.
And I have index cards and I put
them up with pins and I have bits.
I have a one star,
two star and three star.
One star is a completely new bit, two
stars a bit. That's still improving.
Three stars is a bit,
that's pretty close to being done.
They always grow and change and get weird.
And there's always like new directions
they take on certain shows and cause I
mixed them up to,
I'll mix up the order of like the
different pieces inside the bit to try to
figure out which way works.
And I like scrivener because I could take
those cards and just move them around.
And sometimes when I'm just studying,
just thinking about my act,
maybe I'll listen to recordings.
It's one of the most
uncomfortable parts of standup.
But I think one of the most important, you
got to listen to pen, see yourself, um,
and, and listen to like, Ooh, I don't like
how I did that. Like there's too much,
too much bullshit and that joke and
that this joke is Kinda clunky and the
wording's not good or the inflection
is too fake or what have you.
You know? So, uh, that
process is a aided by that.
And one of the things that I really
love was going to ask you about is right
room ever use right room. I've used
it just to look on the phone now.
Right room is the one that
takes your entire screen.
It makes it black and gives you that
green screen. We'll do that to you.
Oh it does.
It really Scribner's got a white out or
a blackout feature and I can get sort of
everything on the screen except what
you're reading. So kind of the same thing.
Oh, okay. Cool. Yeah. Well that's right.
Room doesn't give you access to anything.
You can't go to the toolbar. You can't
say what time it is. You don't get shit.
Yeah, that's right. Room. That's what
it looks like. I really, really like it.
It's my favorite.
I,
it's something I probably need to start
using more and Scribner cause I get
distracted trying to stay in touch
with social media and everything else.
And if you're on the computer and
a fan is asking you a question,
the natural impulses to go answer
that question. So, you know,
getting to a point where I can
just ignore all that. But, um,
I was just in Vegas for the new media
expo and when I really get into it and I
was under deadline, so I started writing
at noon. We were staying at the Rio,
don't have the seafood buffet at the rail.
I will tell you that I, how dare you.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
I've said that the top,
the best vomit of my whole life
and has been a lot of vomiting,
clams and a musket. Oh, I don't even
know. I don't know what it was but it was,
it was Linda Blair shit.
It was crazy. But I'm,
I'm writing and it's like noon out and
like there's the window and the window is
open and by the time I got finished it
looked out and it was pitch black outside.
So sometimes I can't imagine it's the
same thing when you're writing more of the
short form jokes and moving
around from the jokes.
But for this long form
things like 50 page story,
I had my own screen came up and I,
that's all I was working on.
I didn't look at anything else. Just
wrote the whole thing through. Yeah.
You can get in those zones. Uh, I
don't write jokes like joke jokes.
What I do is I write about subjects and
I find the jokes in what I write about
it when he went. What I find is
that when I'm writing about things,
it takes longer for me to write the word
history then for me to think of it or
know it exists. If I'm thinking
about history, I can think about it.
But I have to say his tier.
I mean I have to actually individually
type all the letters and in that you,
you have much more consideration to
every sentence that you write every,
every chapter,
every concept because you're,
you're thinking a lot quicker than your
writing. So as you're writing it down,
you're considering deeply each,
it's like its forces you to pause
and consider each individual word,
consider the, the, the,
the concept you're actually talking about
far more than if you were just having
a conversation. You're having a
conversation. It takes more, it takes,
it's much quicker to get the words out.
Right. I think in that slowing you down,
it makes you consider things more and
then sometimes you'll just miss like
really obvious shit that you would
have missed it if you were talking,
but when you're riding like,
oh, and what about this?
And then you'll go off
in some other directions.
Like you give your brain like a
different rhythm. The rhythm of writing.
No talking, no, no, no distractions, no
fucking music. Stop all the nonsense.
Lock the door, hit the right room
and just go. Yeah. Do you find,
do you find you have to go for a certain
amount of time before all of a sudden
shit starts to take off? I'm useless
for the first half hour. Yeah. Yeah.
Sometimes I,
I don't even take credit for the things
I write because it's not me writing them.
You know? It's your inner,
your inner muse. We'd wrote
it. We wrote that one. No,
I don't know how that one in me,
I,
I'm like the first 30 minutes
are usually just trash,
absolute trash work and then at some
point something just takes over and you're
making really good stuff.
It's interesting, isn't it?
That that weird switch that goes off
where you find yourself really zen in what
you're doing? For me it is
probably around the same time,
about 30 minutes in 2030 minutes. The
first 20 minutes, I don't even think,
I'm just trying to smash keys and
write things down and just thinking,
but just kind of getting
into it and trying to,
and then somewhere along the line
you catch traction. My add is so bad.
Now I've got a technique like I'll just
set the alarm on the phone instead of 30
minutes and then I'm like, okay, I'm
just not going to look at anything else.
I can do this for 30 minutes. It's just
starting that that bad. That's bad.
Force yourself to write for 30 minutes,
doesn't matter what you write and then
almost invariably by the time the buzzer
goes off, you're just like turn it off
and you're just like, cause you're,
you're rolling at that point,
but you have to force yourself to be like,
I have to get into that groove.
My groove is usually also
to move around the house.
I like to pick up my laptop and go sit
somewhere else, go sit in my uh, you know,
sit in my living room, go sit
upstairs, go sit in front of the TV.
You don't even watch TV. Just sit on the
couch. And I think that when I do that,
instead of just being in my office and
stare at the screen sometimes just being
in a different space, sitting
in a different place, just
go, oh, we're here now.
And that just that
changing of your routine,
just a little variation on it sometimes
can spark the mind an interesting new
direction.
Yeah.
You get,
you get down these wormholes and just
getting any other kind of sensory input,
which goes back to now I'm going to write
things down instead of type them out
or anything like that can
cause it's all in there.
All that stuff you want to come up
with is in there. It's not like you're,
you know, it's not like you have a factory
where you have to make all this crap.
It's all already in there.
You just kind of getting,
figuring out how to mine it out of your
own brain and put it onto the page,
you know? And I also find super
beneficial. A Walk, a walk. Yeah. Walk,
you know, and uh, used to
bring a recorder, but now
with these new cell phones,
you don't have to know your phone can
record amazing notes and I just go for a
walk, walk my dogs or something
like that, go down the street.
And just when I'm thinking about something
and I've got something in my head and
I'm done writing and then I'm reviewing
the things that I wrote and like,
how would I, how would I view this
if I was a person who was reading it?
Like how would I, how would
I take this? Like I'll,
I'll take it into consideration as I'm
walking. It's like the fat, you know,
there's something about forcing yourself
to do a mundane, very obvious task.
Left foot, right foot,
left foot, right foot,
and then you can get into that groove
of introspective thought. Yeah.
Yeah. And it does. Some of
that to me is like I've,
I've got this little tiny office,
but there's like a loop.
There's like four rooms and you actually
go from kitchen to this room to the
entryway to the writing room.
And I just don't do labs,
so I just started doing laps and it
usually doesn't take very long because
you're turning right all the
time, every two steps. And it's,
there's something about your brain has
to put some level of attention on and not
walking into things. And that usually
comes from the part that's blocking you.
The part that stopped me,
like you're convincing yourself,
you can't get this shit out
and now, okay. Oh, all right.
Boom that run back to the desk
and start writing things down
really quick. Have you ever tried using
speech recognition software for writing?
Right.
Wouldn't work for me only because I'm,
by the time I block a sentence down,
it's probably already be written, been
rewritten three times. Start the sentence,
go back, start sentence, go back. And
unfortunately a pretty fast typer.
I learned that a long time ago. It
was, I knew I wanted to write and yeah,
I just changed things.
Sell fast like it's all muscle memory now.
It's like copy this, paste
this, move this around. I,
I cannot imagine speech
recognition would ever work for me.
The um, uh, Mavis beacon teaches
typing. That's the one I owe, I owe.
That made us bake and she goes,
yeah,
that was a for me meant
I was the poker guy. Yep.
Looking right at them. It took a
long time. Genius product. Like no,
just play video games pitch.
He goes and like what?
I'm just playing video games and all
of a sudden I can type, it was amazing.
Amazing.
And it's their fun games.
Like you're racing and share that you're
doing all kinds of different stuff and
figuring out where the little keys
are. That's, that's so important, man.
I used to have one of those
goofy keyboards. It was
like separated split ones.
Yeah. And your hands rest on it and ship
those died off. What happened there?
Economic.
I just want to be working on my end.
I don't think they worked for crap.
They're supposed to be good for you.
I had the one that actually was like
a transformer. It actually had a hand.
You went out to the sides. That thing
was bad ass. Did you ever get it? Get
the one where you sink in,
you sink your fingers in.
There was a weird one like this.
Fingers like sitting in a cradle.
I still have to look like every now and
then I'm still glancing down to get some
kind of tracking going on,
which I don't need to do any more,
but it can't break myself of the
habit like I can, I can I do this.
Sometimes when I'm all
overwhelmed with an idea,
I'll just close my eyes and just start
typing so I don't need to do it anymore,
but I'm still, I can't break that
habit of looking down at the screen.
That's ancient. That's the
thing. Look at that. Yeah.
Yeah. I had one of those. Yeah,
there was those and then there was the
Microsoft ones are a little bit more
curly and they had like a us an actual
space in between. Didn't separate.
They're just,
it's more like lumpy.
They called them ergonomic keyboard makes
those things anymore. I don't think,
I don't know.
You know what the problem is,
you get used to those and then you go to
a laptop and it's feels weird. You know,
a lot of people are typing
their stuff on laptops now.
So like the way you learn how to type on
a laptop is you want your fingers to be
right in that position of j and
f the fingers across the board.
And then from there you go.
If you go back and forth from
laptop to keyboard delight,
this is like a thinking part.
We have to like a quarterback changing.
You're throwing lotions to
change everything around.
Yeah. It fucks with you. Yeah.
But the speech recognition software is
fascinating to me because I wonder if
that I'll ever be something that
I'm interested in because, uh,
for the walks, I have to imagine,
you know. Right. You're walking,
you're still speak everything down.
No, I just record it. Right.
And Go back and listen to, yeah.
I go back and listen to it.
I really find that there's a
completely different state of mind. Uh,
the actual writing state of mind,
and I find that I'm way more creative
when I could just sit in total silence,
not hear my voice or anybody's
voice and the right, I'll,
I'll allow my brain to go in all sorts
of weird directions when they're not,
it's not attached to flowing,
moving language.
Ideas can serve emerge instantaneously
and I just try to follow them and capture
them in writing. I think a, I limit
myself when I'm actually talking.
Hmm. Yeah, yeah. Know it comes to
writing things. Yeah. It, it's for me,
but at this point it's just down to,
it's a process.
Now I've got the process going and
getting more and more comfort with the
process. So hopefully I'm
growing towards that. You know,
Stephen King's process is just so fast
that your process is also very creative.
I mean, you have to have this
idea. You have to have the story,
you have to create this story.
That part's never people.
Some people talking about writer's block,
I've never had that.
I've had the opposite,
which is just this on slot of cool ideas.
Like this would be a good book.
And this be a good book and trying to
try and keep track of everything. So the,
the creative part,
um,
being a scatter little kid fortunately
just has never been an issue for me.
It's all it with me.
It's always been the discipline of being
able to write it down and trying to
fight the add and you know,
and like I have to keep working on
this to make it the best it can be.
When after the first draft, I'm kind
of already done with it. I'm like, oh,
I want to, I want to go do
something else, but you can't.
You got to go back and keep
hammering on that sword,
making it make it a good
weapon. Yeah, that's,
that's really interesting that it's the,
the different of
creative processes that all
try to achieve the same thing.
Whether it's a song or a
movie or a book or, or a joke.
It's this completely fascinating to me,
the different ways that people
approach it in different,
the different mindsets they
have in approaching it too.
You know this, that there's,
there's no one pattern,
which is what's fascinating about
the human brain and everybody's got a
different way of doing it and just keep
working at it till you get to that end
product and where you can hopefully
look at what you finished with.
And I think all creative people
kind of have the same thing.
You probably have it too,
like that's a pretty good joke.
That's not the best it could possibly be,
but I think that's pretty good.
That's going to go in the arsenal
for the next stand up. And with me,
it's like that book is pretty good.
I would work on that book
for the next 10 years,
every day to try and make
everything perfect. But you
know, at least for me there,
there is no perfection. Like,
and here's some others go.
I keep working on until
I've absolutely the perfect,
the perfect phrase and the perfect
sentence in a perfect paragraph and the
perfect page, that's great. But you know,
we got to put a book out and sell some
books so I can't work on a book for 10
years. Yeah, it's never perfect
either because your perception,
sins of it change radically from d.
I mean like there's stuff that I enjoyed
that I did just a couple of years ago
that if I have to watch now, I don't, I
don't know. Yeah, anything to do with it.
I don't want to watch it.
I want to listen to it.
Ron, I mean just to 24 months ago
I'm like, I don't want to hear it.
I've gotten to the point now
where unless it's for research,
I don't go back and reread the old books.
And I heard an interview with
Bryan Cranston on Nerdist
that really helped a ton
with that,
which you know when he's just kicking
everybody's ass at breaking bad and he's
like the baddest actor ever at this
moment. He was really focused on,
he puts everything he has
into that performance and
then the second he walks off
the set he's done. He's like, I'm
not paying attention to that anymore.
I'm moving on to the next thing I
did as best I can. So with my books,
cause I get worked every time I reread a
book and find a mistake or some kind of
goof up or something,
the character motivation isn't right.
I get super angry and super worked up.
So now I just don't read that stuff.
Like it's got to go.
Well I think
that you sort of, when, when
you're done with a project,
you've internalized everything that you're
gonna learn from that everything that
you've, you know, I, I feel like
as an artist, as a crafts person,
whether it's a writer or
anything or a musician,
I think you're getting better all the
time or you're not getting better.
It's one of the two.
Either you're getting better all the
time and you're constantly working on
improving things or you're not.
And um,
there's only a certain amount of time
that you should consider the past certain
amount of time he consider past work.
And cause if you consider it,
you're really robbing yourself,
present work,
you're really robbing yourself of the
focus that you could be using on working
on the shit that you thinking about
right now. So in that mindset,
I just start getting repulsed,
repulsed by my old stuff.
Like I don't want to talk.
How's
it [inaudible] if I find myself on TV,
I go flip the channel.
The other day I was in my car two times
in a row and raw dog was playing my
comedy. I'm like, shut up. I want to
fucking hear me. I don't want to hear me.
I don't want to even think that I was
a different person 10 years ago and I'm
concentrating on right now. I had
experience recently stand up. Uh,
not,
I'm not doing standup listening.
Stand up that show me how
much I have changed as a
person and I'm on Pandora all.
I listened to his, uh, comedy on Pandora.
That's like when I'm not writing. Okay,
I got to pick up the opposite.
Got to clean up.
Let's put out some comedy on Pandora
and just let that cycle through and hear
new stuff. And I started a new channel
for the Andrew dice clay channel and I go,
now, I was in college, we were all crazy
for dice. Like there was like we get,
we gathered in the room and
watch VHS, it'd be like eight
guys. Why? Just like, ah,
you're the best. And then I'm listening
to it now and I'm remembering these,
hearing him do all these old bits
and I'm like, Oh, I love this bit.
And then I'm listening
to it. I'm like, yeah,
this isn't really all
that funny to me anymore.
This is so racist and so massage
and this and that. Like, you know,
like somebody who's really good at racist
team right now as is Daniel tosh like
can do it in a way that
doesn't make you uncomfortable.
Like I don't know how he does it, but
listen to Andrew dice. Clay was like this,
I don't, this isn't for me.
And more aggressive. Yeah,
well it's in the bowl bitch.
Oh. And I realized like I was, what
we were all laughing at was that,
that amazing the delivery is
delivering is timing were great,
but the actual subject matter was,
and I'm like,
I cannot believe how much I have changed
that I don't find this funny anymore.
See I've gotten more immature and
I find it funnier. Is that right?
Because what I know he's doing is he's
doing an act. Yeah. Doing a character,
you know,
he makes things up like his characters
is preposterously ridiculously oversexed
asshole, you know, and
you know what to expect.
So I enjoy it from this completely non
politically correct approach that he's
doing. Like as a, you know, that's his
act. That's what he's chosen to do. Right.
I mean he could easily start doing
clean jokes and concentrate on that. No,
he's gotten dirty or he wears
weightlifting. Gloves is good.
His hair slicked back.
He's wearing a fanny pack and
he's talking about sucking Dick.
Oh, it's fun. Big Glasses.
It's, he's got giant old lady,
old Jewish lady I seen as new
step in awhile. He's Larry.
We saw him in Vegas.
It was me,
Brian Anthony from opie and Anthony
and Jim Norton and Bobby Kelly.
A bunch of comedians. And we fucking
cried laughing. Yeah, it was so,
cause it was for us. First of all, we
know it's an act. We know it's comedy.
We know. I mean we,
we've been aware of it.
I was a huge fan before ever got into
comedy, so to be there like in Vegas,
having a couple of cocktails and be
able to watch, just sit there and watch.
It was fucking hell. I bet. I bet. Live.
It's still pretty impressive. Ridiculous.
He's talking about how to catch fag, how
you catch, how you make it a gay kid.
It was so ridiculous. It was so
ridiculous. Like talking about how
so you get fig like he,
he's trying to get more and
more preposterous. There's,
there's all right. All of
us, there's all of us. After the
show is, it was really fucking funny.
I mean me and Jimmy Norton and
Brian and we were crying, laughing.
It was really funny.
But it's ridiculous.
There's an art form in sang ridiculous
shit. You don't really mean. Right,
and that's what I think dice
does. Right? But if you, yeah,
if you were alone in your car,
if you're in your home and
you're completely sober and
you're listening to some
of the horrible things, he
said like, what the fuck, man,
I'm uncomfortable laughing at this now.
I don't know what that says about me.
It's fiction. It's, you know,
if from the characters tractive I catch
a ton of shit for my books. Do you? Yeah.
I get people, like, people are so caught
up in their own, this is who I am.
You can make fun of everybody
else outside of this area.
But the second you touch on my area,
you're a dick.
So I get it in black,
like me talking about dice clay right now,
I get people like, I can't believe
your, that massage Mike. No,
that's this asshole character.
That's not me. That's the character.
And people can't,
some people can't differentiate that,
but nobody has a problem with it until
it's their particular area. Yes. Yeah.
If you're picking on vegans or
transsexuals, are Republicans, right?
Getty you that Natasha Leggiero a
thing that happened over the weekend?
No. Yeah, she, she made a
joke. Uh, she was doing,
Carson Daly had a new year's show in
Times Square and she made a joke about a
old folks and,
um,
World War Two and Pearl Harbor
and she got more fucking hate,
like unbelievable amounts
of people were angry at her.
So she made a non-apology put it on
our website and she's like, fuck,
it's beautiful, you know,
to, to do that in the fake,
her apology was brilliantly written to
which she said is she was called a cunt
so many times. She thought she was in a
British pub rooting for the wrong thing.
Soccer team,
her originally
joke wasn't even a Pearl Harbor joke.
It was just a denture joke about old
people eating spaghettio's because
spaghetti has got so much shit for having
that image of a spaghetti holding an
American flag that they put up on Pearl
Harbor Day just to kind of show respect
now, you know? And then they were like,
what? How dare you, you know what?
It was the actual joke. Do you have a,
yeah, I'll pull it up. But it was a,
uh, hold on. Yeah.
There's a lot of people out there that
fucking love to be offended. Oh yeah.
I live in San Francisco
for crying out loud.
Well yes,
there's a lot in there and they love to
talk about being offended and they love
to get angry at you
because they're offended.
Well you, uh, you are big on the Internet.
I'm sure you deal with that daily basis.
Look at that. And then Tagetik
live. Hold on, scroll up. Scroll up.
Popular comedian living
today. She's cool. I love her.
Pandora just introduced me to her like
a couple of weeks ago. She's great.
She's very nice too. She's a nice, nice
person. Stated two of my friends too. Hmm.
Now three cause I like
Moshe to uh, yeah, she,
but she wrote on her thing. She's not
apologizing for shit. I love it. Cool.
Yeah.
Cause there's always people out there
that are going to want you to apologize
for something that's fucking
ridiculous to apologize.
They're always going to exist.
I got the,
the most recent one that came up and
you don't think it's bad until somebody
actually kind of calls you
on it in the book. Nocturnal.
There's a character who has
Tourette's syndrome and also has a,
a voicebox has lost his voice,
a voice box due to throat cancer.
So it's kind of preposterous. And then
he's always talking to the main character,
trying to make main character like fuck
are Brecker sacred dick or soccer and
like it's this crazy
combination of things,
which is actually a true story that a
friend of mine who got arrested was in the
drunk tank and there was a, there
was a guy with the, you know,
the voice box and he had Tourette's.
And he's telling me the story of bar.
I'm like, that's so going in a book. Are
you kidding me? That's fucking awesome.
And then one of my longtime fans finally
listens to this book and we do the
audio books and it's really over the
top when we do it in the audio books,
it sounds like the guy from south
park basically. And uh, she's like,
that's not funny. I have treads.
And I'm like, you're like, okay.
So now you have to write because
it's directly impacts are,
and it looks like we're mocking her, but
you have to write an apology. We're like,
yeah, I'm not gonna apologize for
the story because it's a character.
But you know, it's unfortunate that that
hit you in your, your personal soft spot,
so to speak. And I didn't
mean to marginalize you, but
I'm not changing the story.
It's great
funny though that it,
if it's like someone can say that's not
funny and then you're not allowed to
talk about it.
But if it wasn't funny at all,
if it was like a tragic situation where
a person had Tourette's and it was out
of control and is in a story,
then that would be different
because that's not mocking.
That's not putting into a comedy.
You know, like you could depict it.
You can depict Tourette's and depict
Tourette's being an issue that maybe,
you know, the people that
actually have it can say, oh,
that's very similar to what I have to
deal with. And they would be fine with it.
But it's making the laughs out of it.
Yeah.
That and that's what ticked off this
fan and finding them. It's weird
even being able to explain like,
well,
the point of the joke is that you never
know whether he has it or not or he's
just using it as an excuse to be an
asshole to everybody. Um, but you know,
and that, that, that one person,
that's what every character that I create
goes through something to that effect
where somebody calls out and
goes, yeah, that's not funny
dude. Yeah, but they're fucking
assholes. They really are.
They're really assholes.
And there's self serving clients because
you really have to look at the big
picture. I mean, you, you're
telling, what are we saying?
Are we saying that
Tourette's doesn't exist?
We saying that people aren't crazy
and the dude's don't have voice boxes.
Like what combination of these
things is unrealistic. Yeah.
And also it's also a story
about cannibalistic monsters
living under the streets
of San Francisco. Yeah. Fuck fictional
fun. Ya know, people are cons man.
If you pick on lesbians, they will come
after you with fucking baiting here.
They are very quick to raise their
defense. Vegetarians also furious.
Vegans are me. Armenians go after
Armenians. Watch what happens.
They'll fucking kill you.
Yeah. Here's the no kill you,
the beat you in the streets
if you want to look at it.
It's pretty much just the Jay Leno joke
here.
Harbor Day,
they sent out a tweet featuring their
mascot holding an American flag,
asking people to quote,
take a moment to remember Hashtag
[inaudible] Pearl Harbor with us.
It offended a lot of people [inaudible]
sentimental American historic
traditions, seemingly looking for
people in business and it wasn't good.
But you are offended for another reason.
They're referring to spaghetti. I says,
that's it.
That's actually a good joke. Yeah,
that's a good joke. Fuck, fuck over that.
Wendy's is that. It's um, I forgot
that dude's name and Anthony. Yeah,
Anthony Anderson. That didn't seem all
that bad to me. That wasn't bad at all.
Fuck everybody. But if I was
a survivor, real Pearl Harbor,
that'd be a different ballgame.
But her response was so perfect because
she was like one of the few people that
didn't like bow down and take
it and just say, I'm sorry.
Even though she didn't mean it.
And her response is so great
because she's a real comic.
Steve Martin is on a comic anymore.
Steve Martin,
apologize for like one
of the lamest jokes ever.
Some silly tweet where
he's talking about Lasagna,
like spelling it differently if you
were African Americans like cause like
spelling it like the pronunciation.
Like they would say Lasagna or something
like that. I don't remember what it was.
It was,
it was just a joke and people would bid
his fucking head off and he pulled the
tweet and apologize.
Oh Steve,
listen to who changed. Things have
changed for Steve. Silly Bitch. You're,
you're listening to dummies.
Just cause they can talk to
you doesn't mean they're smart.
Just because they could reach
It's so hard to keep a
perspective sometimes too.
You get two or three tweets and I,
I some,
I've seen some of the tweet hazing
that you've got or the tweet conflicts,
whatever. And like all of a sudden
you have this large audience,
but these 50 people are focused on it
and like you got to pay attention to it.
Right. You at least have to have
some kind of response to it. But
fuck 'em all Scott at that block. But
you don't want to like be on follow me.
Oh,
enjoy my block. Yeah. Um, no,
I don't engage a man because you can
engage them when we can engage the people
that are being nice. Sometimes I'll
engage people in a mocking way if I,
if I'm giggling at them.
But to get actually angry at
them for what? To actually say.
There's one thing if you did something
wrong or if there's like some sort of a
remorse that you have for your actions
and maybe someone's reacting to that.
Something Real, not like this
Natasha thing that was, you know,
it's possible you could fuck up and say
something he didn't really mean or you
said it too quickly,
didn't realize how ridiculous it
wasn't till after he said it. Yeah.
But if there's none of that
and then you're getting hate,
like what are you doing?
You're going to just pay attention to
people that just look to hate people for
no fucking reason.
Are they living in the past?
Is there can be times too where
somebody says something like, Geez,
I never thought about it from
that particular perspective.
And that's a logical perspective. So yeah,
I'll, I'll re rethink what I said there,
but that's pretty rare. Well, I, um,
have one thing that I really
do enjoy and it's a, a
lot of people were very uncomfortable
with when they get hyper criticized when
someone like attacks them and tax them
in a way that actually makes sense.
But I think those people that do that,
um,
whether they like it or not, they're
helping you because even if they're wrong,
they're forcing you to consider whether
or not there's any merit in what they're
saying. And if you can't find any
merit and what they're saying,
then you relieved of any future
attacks like that. Like it's like, oh,
you're another one.
No,
you're another crazy person that
has a distorted view of reality.
And the reason why you have this distorted
view of reality can be many, many,
many, many different reasons. You could
be fucking jealous. You could be crazy,
you could be psychotic, you could just do
that. I've gotten to people's twitters,
like they'll,
they'll,
they'll say something hateful to you and
you think about responding and then you
go to their Twitter feed and it's
just them attacking everyone.
Fucking Dimi more to Koby Bryant
to fucking anybody can find.
That's what some people
do. They just, they,
they throw out a bunch of different lures
and hope somebody bites and not even a
real person.
I unfortunately,
I,
I pretty much weaned myself from looking
at Amazon reviews anymore cause there's
just some assholeishness that goes
on there like nobody's business.
Youtube is the center of,
oh I can't,
I don't even look at those
youtube comments on Amazon.
I'll go and once in a while I'll
see a one star review and you know,
like I worked my ass off for two years.
You son of a bitch,
what do you got to say about it?
And once in a while they're like,
they take the book apart and
like from your perspective,
I can see that's a crappy book
the way you see it, no problem.
But most of them are just,
they didn't actually read the book.
Like you can tell from the review,
like they read 20 pages and stopped and
gave you a one star review and you get
all super pissed off and then you go
and you click on that and you'd read
through their other reviews and
it's just like endless stars.
One star reviews and like five stars
or twilight and you're like, okay,
that's not really my audience.
You know what I've found really
fascinating about people like that,
the people who are really harsh on like
writers or movies or what have you,
and you read their criticisms and
there's often a lot of work put into that
stuff.
A lot of work put into the criticisms.
Like I've gotten people's Yelp pages.
You'd read like a really evil
Yelp and you're like, okay,
let's go to this guy's Yelp
page and see what he, you know,
he hates this restaurant so much.
Let's see what he says about everything
and everything is like really well
written destruction of of various
restaurants or various things and you go,
oh, I see what that guy's doing. He's,
he's distracting himself
from his own failures.
He's attacking everything
is being mediocre and not
even realizing how ironic it
is. He's put all of his
energy into criticizing other
people's work because he's
avoiding doing his own.
That's a big thing with a lot of these
like bloggers and critics and people that
are right. What are they actually doing
here? You're writing a bunch of evil,
evil shit, but what are you actually
contributing other than your opinion?
Dog Shit.
Yeah.
What do you, what do you
make, what do you put up?
What do you put out in the world? Like
the people whose whole world is nothing,
but I'm going to rip on Coby Brian,
I'm going to,
I'm going to come out and rip on
Lebron James for under achieving
and you're like,
what the fuck do you do?
What do you want this guide
to do for Christ sakes,
like that thing and then the Yelp and
people ripping on everything. You're like,
just if you don't like the way they do it,
go do it and something great yourself.
I very rarely attack journalists,
but I have gone after a few
MMA journalists who have
written evil shit about
fighters. Just really nasty, stupid,
fucking hurtful snarky shit. Right? And
the only reason why they're doing it,
it's just their comments, you know? And
you got to expose them for what they are.
I mean,
just because someone falls short is
because someone tries and gets beat up by
someone who's better than them,
you know,
have some respect for that process
of development, of understanding,
of exploration, of adventure that these
fighters go on for your entertainment,
the sacrifice they have to make
just to be able to get in that ring.
And like if you show up in the UFC cage,
you've,
you've already done an enormous amount
of shit. Stunning, stunning sacrifices.
Even when they make horrible
excuses for why things went wrong,
in my opinion, that has to be treated
with an objective sense of respect.
You have to understand that
psychologically they're
defeat is unbelievably
brutal.
That a fighter going through a defeat,
like they're looking for some reason
to stay alive when they're telling you
they're very raw.
W I had staff and then I got the flu
and then maybe those things are true,
but the reason why they have to tell you
about those things is they're fucking
falling apart their life into their
calling and looking for something to gain
some sort of a victory.
Like he might've kicked my ass,
but I was in a car accident six weeks ago,
man,
I had to deal with insurance and they
find some reason to give them some reason
that they're worth something.
And you'd like those journalists once in
a while to say something to the effect
of yeah, that was bad. UFC fight,
it's still better than any UFC fight I've
ever been in because I've never gotten
in the ring in my frigging life.
I don't think they have to say that.
I think they just have to treat the
situation with respect and they have to
treat what a fighter is actually doing
and they have to treat it differently
than playing basketball.
Cause it's not the fucking,
same thing when a basketball games lost,
if you go home crying and freaking out,
you probably a baby. Okay. But when
you get your ass kicked in there,
that guy stole a little piece of your
life. He stole some happiness from you.
And if you don't, if you don't
respect that, it's because
nobody ever beat you up.
If somebody, if you ever
fought and someone kicked
your ass, you would realize,
you know, it's like this is not
a good feeling at all and we'll,
let's just analyze what happened
in the fight itself. You know,
if you want a psychologically breakdown,
what,
what's wrong with the guy and where
it goes wrong to do it with respect.
It can be done with respect.
But W we have as a bunch of really
shitty writers who only get attention by
being negative. That's, but
that's been the sports writing.
That's why I got on sports radio,
sports radio.
It's sports writing.
And I've been like really disrespectful
to those guys because I don't think that
has any place in martial arts.
I believe if you want to get
shitty about a football player,
if that's your tradition,
that's fine.
But if you want to add that same sports
guy, bullshit, talk to martial arts,
I say fuck you. You don't know
what you're talking about, right?
You don't know what
you're some fucking dummy.
Some dumb dumb football guy does.
Amateur football was talking about
Anderson Silva breaking his leg and he's
saying, this is why I would never cover
MMA and I don't watch it. Never will.
You know,
and like dummy,
you're a part of the number one
sport for traumatic brain injuries,
the number one football,
and you're also amateur football,
which means he didn't even get paid.
So the university's pimp these kids out,
they make fucking billions of
dollars on college football.
That's what you cover.
And you make your living off of it
while the players make none and they're
getting fucking brain damage left and
right. And you're complaining about MMA,
just fuck you dummy you sports dummy.
Yeah,
a bunch of these sports dummies and being
a former small time sports writer and
a former like small time college athlete,
they being able to see both of those
sides of the coin and anybody competing at
that level.
Just the amount of work and talent just
to get to be sucky at something because
astronomical and most of
these writers have never,
they've never done anything even close
to what they're talking about and their
whole career is based on
how much of a dick can I be.
Much intention and that's how they
got attention for the longest time.
I don't think that that's going to last
anymore. I think that that sort of,
that was fine when everything was
being distributed by media networks.
When everything that you,
you couldn't really comment on it.
If you were a fan of Jim Rome, the radio
show 10 years ago or so. I mean how,
what kind of feedback could
you ever give him, you know,
get there was no fried back and
when he did something controversial,
people listened and they watch. It was an
adequate way of gathering up attention.
But I think that these want to be guys
and these guys that are coming along now
that are trying to do that,
they're really fucking themselves by
playing this act of being this, you know,
really Shitty, you know, sports guy talk.
Because I think ultimately that's
going to be exposed as being a really
ineffective way of communicating negative
and not really fun to listen to either.
The judgmental level,
I don't know that that'll ever go away
because I think unfortunately a lot of
the people watching this stuff want
way to feel better about themselves and
bitching about players is still huge.
It has no place in martial arts.
It will never work in martial
arts. That's good. That's,
it could be an oasis of logic then
in the world of assholery. Well,
the stakes are higher than any other
sport. The stakes are the emotional state.
And so his break, that's pretty
tough. Well, that happens in football.
That happens in basketball and I have
been catastrophic injuries and almost
every kind of really physical
explosive sport. It's unavoidable. And,
but what Anderson they break that he
had was very unusual. I've only been,
I've only seen two of
those ever live in person,
and I've called well
over a thousand fights.
There's was probably close to 1500 fights
in my career doing commentary. Right.
I've only seen it twice. So it's pretty
rare. So for someone to point that out,
that's why I don't watch MMA
or never worked ridiculous.
Every stupid cheerleading has
catastrophic and has paralysis, death,
crazy high school.
Cheerleading is really fucking dangerous.
They're flipping each other.
Doing Pyramids just started that crap
and I'm very nervous about it is very
scary to let me ask a question.
Can you guys play my pandemic trailer for
the book? Fuck you. Then I can hit the,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that coffee? When and
how long have you, oh yeah,
please. Two minutes were very rude and
asking people to sit here for three hours.
I don't give a shit. This
is awesome. Any time,
just feel free to go to youtube
and look for Scott Sigler pandemic.
I'm just going to talk shit
about you as soon as I know.
I know because you haven't,
you haven't accomplished anything.
Josie got to drag me down. How
rude. Go drill down. Where is your,
um, where's your trailer at?
Deserves a second yet for it.
Is there a specific websites? Foul mouth
though. It's got swearing in it. That's,
we'd like that.
Yes.
Is there a way that folks at home
can go and they can see a URL?
They can all find it at Scott's a
go.com/pandemic that's got the youtube
embedded right there. Or
just go to youtube and search
for Scott Sigler pandemic.
I liked that. A authors are doing this
now making youtube. Whoops. There we go.
Holy Shit.
They come around me and they die.
It takes like a,
maybe like a full hours are sober.
They die
just like a fucked up.
Is this
Chris?
Ooh, hard. Stephen King Park. Chuck,
try to pronounce that last name.
Antibodies.
Palo of dead dead.
They're all dead because of me.
Get me.
Please come and get me.
I make these assholes.
Do you want to save the world
and they're fucking seat.
Yeah.
Dogs for excited.
What is it like to see your words come
to life in a visual form like that?
It's awesome. It's awesome
because you got, uh, you know,
you've got to give that over to somebody
who's creative in a different area than
you. And like I do, you know, we, we
picked out parts of the book, like an
actual scene from the book.
We could turn it in that trailer
and then gave it over these guys,
the company's name,
res Gregson there,
here in a l a u r e s Grex I
think the gay guy who directed,
it's name's Adrian Bacardi.
And he already shot a couple a thing
earlier for ancestor, but said,
do this and then have to watch
how he does the whole thing.
And they shot that in the same
warehouse where they filmed a inception.
And so that was pretty fucking sweet.
You know, you get to it and you're like,
Holy Shit, this is where they shot
that one movie. And it was pretty fun.
But it's a,
it's thrilling to watch what other people
do with your work because you know,
you, I don't do that. So I have
to see how they bring it to life.
It's gotta be weird. It's
totally weird. He made that.
When they make a movie about your books,
man, is that going to trip you out?
Completely going to trip me
out because you as the author,
you see everything in your head. You
know how it's exactly supposed to look.
But when the director gets a hold of
it and the producer gets a hold of it,
they're seeing something else and they're
the ones who make the pictures move.
So you got to kind of go
with what they go with.
I mean what we're trying to do as we
work toward getting infected to be a TV
series and nocturnal Libby TV series is
just trying to make myself indispensable
to these guys.
Like I'm always here.
I'm always ready to answer questions and
ready to go to work for you anytime you
want.
So that if it comes to one of those
points where like I think what you want to
show might not exactly be
what the fans want to see.
Maybe you can influence that,
but that's all you can hope for is to
influence things a little bit because
that's not your job. Your,
their job is to make movie.
I remember when Steven King first
saw the shining, he was very upset.
He was very upset with even
Jack Nicholson's performance
cause Jack Nicholson
was crazy from the jump
and he didn't want that.
And he wanted there to be an arc where
you see this normal guy slowly start to
fall apart.
Whereas he felt like Jack Nicholson was
like so borderline unhinged from the
beginning of the,
of the movie.
It was just a completely
different movie than the book.
And then they did that one with the
dude from wings. Yup. They did the uh,
the full version of it. Stephen King. But
it was like, it was too late. You know,
it's really hard to do.
Well,
they're competing against one of the
icons of American film. You know,
the shining film is, you know, like it
or hate it. That's, that's an every top,
top 100 out there.
Cause he's just so dramatic.
Kubrick is such a bad motherfucker.
I mean his movies were so incredible.
He was so weird too.
Like he did shit in that movie where
the guy was getting blown by the stuffed
animal. Like what the fuck for? He's
going to turn on that shit. What the fuck?
Like his movie was so weird,
so strong and but the Stephen King
apparently just just hated the crap out of
that thing.
But you never really got,
I've never really got the impression
just being a fan that he's all of that
interested in his movie adaptations. He
know he directs, he did maximum overdrive,
which he was very involved
in and a couple other things.
But for the most part he's largely not
part of what goes on in his films it
seems like. So he wonder if that
movie was like, all right, screw this.
I got to be more paid, more
attention to what's going on. Well,
I think he had some huge
moot like carry the original Carrie,
which still to this day,
like they tried to do a new carry and it
just wasn't what every three years now
they do a new carry every three
frigging ears. It just wasn't happening.
The new carry sheet, first
of all, she was too cute.
The girl is the girl from kick
ass. She's adorable. She's cute.
She doesn't really like an outsider.
Chloe Moretz after she moved into a town,
what's that supposed to be
playing, looking, you know,
playing ridge, you know,
and she's like this different.
Yeah,
the girls got old gotta be outside
or different that you know,
which sissy spaces, what
killed it? Fucking per effect.
You just believed her. I believed
her in every way, you know,
and the scene when they,
the fucking pigs blood scene in that movie
where she realized that everybody was
fucking with her and she went
crazy. Woo. Watched that recently.
It's still holds downs up. Stands up real
well. That's what it. Who directed that?
God. I don't know. Find that guy. I
don't know what that stands up and they,
I think they've, I think there have
been three carry remakes. Really? Yeah.
I just saw this one, this more
recent one. I didn't even see it.
I just saw of it and I'm like, get
the fuck Outta here. Yeah. But I'm,
I'm pumped for the Godzilla one. Ah,
fuck yeah. Are you kidding? By the way,
Brian Depalma did carry, yeah. Yeah.
The new Godzilla. I, I the last guy,
Dillon was such a frigging disappointment
to me. I was still upset with that one.
The new one looks pretty
good so far on Matthew.
Broderick was dreaming throughout
the rest of, it was a big fat mass.
Rem was way more of a Mesclun.
Godzilla has disappointed Pacific around.
Oh so bad. Everybody was telling me it
was good too. That was really weird.
Real great action man. You're really
gonna enjoy it. Like you can't vote,
you can't vote anymore.
No specific remedy like that.
What's the worst smell voter?
And then that one part where
like the alien was pregnant
at the end. It was like,
I didn't get that far where I got,
I got with the guy and his ex girlfriend
were arguing and I was like, cut this,
this, this, this is so bad. I feel
like I'm watching a soap opera.
So Barbara made on Mars when I
was bashing it on my Twitter.
There's so many people
got pissed off at me.
Like a lot of people that you'd have
to have good fucking movie, Bro. Well,
it's like we were talking about,
I don't know what other people see.
I don't know what their
perception of reality is.
I have a feeling that there's a bunch
of different perceptions of reality.
It's just like people have different ears
sizes and different brain power and d
people are born with different vision.
I think some people's
perception of reality is
fucking weird and I think that's
why they like shitty music
and they were shitty movies.
I think the full filter that they're
seeing the world through is very different
than the filter that you or I may be.
That filter is shaped by culture
or life experience or the lack of
neurochemicals that I'm enough,
shit and firing and there've been,
they don't eat cholesterol.
Whenever they're missing,
they're missing something and they
see the world in a weird, shocking.
That's always shocking when you
watch a movie and you're like,
I get this all the time. Watch
a movie. I'm like, oh my God,
that's the worst stinking pile
of crusty dog who I've ever seen.
And then you'd go to rotten tomatoes.
It's like 89 90% from the critics.
You're like, why are you fucking people?
Yeah. What did you just fucking watch?
Not that.
Not that I thought that it was that bad,
but with the Pacific criminal thing
that just drove me nuts was I paid good
money to see a giant
monster in a giant robot.
Beat the living shit out of each other.
Can you turn off the frigging rainstorm
so I can see a little bit of detail on
what's going on here? Everything
was all grayed out. I'm like,
that's not why I paid to see this. I
think that you'd wanted to do that though.
So they get hired. The CGI, I
don't think it was that bad though.
I don't think CGI was that bad.
CGI has kept that weird quality to it.
Like when the Hulk Smash,
that alien ship,
you didn't really think the Hawk was
smashing that alien ship. And the vendors,
like you Kinda know at CGI doesn't seem
real right. But if you're watching, like,
did you see rush a race car moving
know when they get in a fucking crash,
that's a fucking crash. You
know? I mean, it's the, the,
the race scenes are very realistic and
you feel like you're actually watching a
real crash. Whereas I feel like, you know,
there's some CGI that it's just like,
I of, he looks great, don't get me
wrong. I saw the new Thor looks great,
but I know that's not really happening.
Right. No, it's not happening. It looks,
it's fake. It's, is it fake enough to
take you out of the story? Yes. Yes it is.
And it isn't. You know, it,
it never allows me to get really deep
into the story because I know it's horse
shit. Right. You know, the shit
that took me out of Thor was like,
knowing exactly what's going to happen,
exactly what's going to happen next,
kind of a thing. You know? Like,
it's just hard to get into that
that particular movie. Well,
that's one of the things that I really
loved about the new hobbit movie is that
the special effects they did
were just enough. I mean,
there was a bunch of craziness.
I don't give any spoiler alerts,
but up until the time they get to
the drag and there's, you know,
the few silly scenes and there was a
lot of fun involved and everything,
but the Gr, the dragon itself was so
well done and the scenes are so well lit,
the whole everything about it. So bad
ass that you go, okay, they did it right.
They did this one right. They nailed
it. They really did nail it. Okay.
But it's hard to do with
CGI was desolation if she
may have in the first one.
Yes, yes. It was definitely
better than the front can't,
it can't be the whole movie and they,
that's part of the problem with Pacific
Rim is, you know, you didn't really,
I didn't really care about any of
those characters. I was just like,
let's get out there and see these giant
things. Beat the shit out of each other.
Dude, that was rooting for the
dragon for the last half hour.
Totally ruined for the Dragon. He's my
favorite person in the movie. He's clever.
He's got a lot of goals.
And that's what pisses me off is that
rotten tomatoes with 72% of that maybe are
71 south Pacific rim.
And,
and I just thought I lost my
mind because acting was horrible.
The script was horrible.
The fact that like you said,
like they didn't even use the sword
until like halfway through the movie and
that's like the best weapon
that robot hat or whatever.
Right. So you, I want to find out
rotten tomatoes for the hobbit.
It'll probably go through
the rough four stars.
70 76% said the Pacific rim.
Well,
it was way better to me at least,
but that's my kind of movie
I saw on the Rogan board.
There's a lot of people on the
message board. The fucking hated it.
They said it was a piece of shit.
They walked out in the middle of it.
Angry little angry,
angry little concern,
but they weren't high command to love it.
I love the trailer trailer looks amazing.
There's two things.
It's not as good as the first one,
but the first one that's so much
headroom in it. You enjoy it anyways.
And the second one, like, take the goddamn
camera. I'll Steve Carell. I'm like,
I'm not. I know this doesn't do anything
for the movie. He's good in little bits,
but he had like 15 minutes of Solo
screentime. Someone's a corral hater. No,
no, no. Not a krill hitters. Just
that character was good. Good.
And he's a punchline. He's not the
whole, these, not the whole joke.
Other than that, it's some funny
shit in that movie. Well, there I am.
A huge will Ferrell fan.
Yeah, he could do no wrong.
I love fucking the step brothers movie.
Yeah,
it was that moving stepbrothers
was called step rose.
I'm a huge towel at Knight Fan.
Talladega nights is fucking hilarious.
God Damn, he's funny. He's just
so stupid and silly, you know,
just really knows how to nail
that silly character. Yeah.
I've not seen anything of his,
I don't like.
Have you seen Casa de mi padre?
It's a serious one.
Is Mexican movie the whole thing?
He talks Spanish and it,
there's no English in the whole entire
movie and it's like an old Mexican movie.
How old is it last
year? Yeah. Oh, no shit.
So it's a new movie. Yeah. I haven't
heard a peep about this. This is a comedy.
Yeah, it's trying to be, it didn't
work, Huh? Well, I mean it's,
it's very low, lower budget because it's
actually, I mean, I only got 5.5 on imdbs,
so it's not that good of a movie.
But it was just interesting to see him
actually play and not using any English
through the whole movie.
It was
remade the three Amigos. That's what
he should've done. That'd be great.
To Talladega nights is one of my all
time favorite. It's just so stupid.
It was so silly and stupid.
Those movies also are good.
They seem to cross generational lines.
Like when I go see my brother,
they want to watch.
They want to watch step brothers.
My nephews want to watch stepbrothers. I
think it's hysterical. I know. I'm like,
I know you're not getting all this humor,
but that's a funny movie.
While you can use,
be surprised,
I think any kid over 10 is probably good
to go with that movie today with the
Internet, they're probably
good to go. They got 10.
They're showing each other each other's
dicks and exchanging email at the same
time. You know, they can handle making
someone eat a pile of poop off the lawn.
It's just funny. No matter how old
you are, that's a good flick. Yeah,
that's good for three year olds.
That'll work.
That'll work for everyone in the family.
Everyone. Except people were uptight.
Joe Have you didn't notice like the,
I'm sure you have noticed the last few
I've see jam man showed me this and now I
can't stop looking at it as,
how many people were headphones now all
around their necks after every fight or
four fight or anything?
Well, no, there's a, the new beats ones
that are, uh, they're, they're wireless.
Have you seen those beats studio wireless.
But yeah,
a lot of people are wearing
like monster ones with no cords.
It's just they're getting paid.
Yeah. That's interesting. Well,
you used to see him with those energy
drinks. You're holed up to energy drink.
Well, you know, I felt the fly really
turned around for me in the second
I actually looked. Uh,
I was watching that. Uh,
you got to see what my wife and we
actually look looking at the headphones.
You know, I looked like all the beats.
I'm like, I don't think those are beats.
And then we actually looked up the logo
because it was a different logo for the
monster headphones and all
of a sudden I'm like, wow,
somebody else is getting
in on that action.
This is cause Aryana does not
want to listen to Brittany talk.
That's what she's got these on. They
don't have any dinner, many cords in them.
Brittany's talking some shit and area.
I was like, bitch, I came in here.
You are so pretty. They're both so
pretty. Such a pretty pretty girls.
Oh so pretty. But their monster
beats, they're even more pretty.
They like their tech now they're in the,
I make them make their little
heads look like animate Dallas.
This is a good commercial
for those monsters.
The wireless ones where there's
a dude who's on a team bus,
he's apparently going
somewhere way against Kevin
girl exit the bus and then he
puts those on and the music plays and
they're all saying go home, go home.
And he's smiling just walking past
everybody's Kevin Garnett. Yeah.
He's a basketball player who used to play.
You just play for Boston Celtics and I
can't think who he was playing for now,
but I believe the bus is going back
to Boston and people are booing him.
He puts those things out and he does it.
It's a great commercial.
That's excellent. You, they should all
be mouthing nick? I don't think so.
I don't think so. Austin, if you
really want to show what could happen,
I don't really want to sell
some fucking soundproof.
He also brought them a chair.
He helped bring them a championship,
so I don't know. Yeah, but if they're
really angry, Boston people trust me.
They'll say,
I'm comfortable with this conversation.
Joel's extremely uncomfortable with all
of this. Now you're an author. Come on,
I'm making fiction.
Putting words into people's mouths.
I'm making characters the asshole
racist character from Boston. Yes,
and that could someday going to book and
that's the bad guy. Here's a question.
When you are confronted
with scenarios like that,
like say if you have a racist
character in your film or in your role,
you're a book rather and
you're constructing him.
Do you hold back on certain things you
think other people would find offensive
or do you try to paint him
in as vile away as possible?
Which would include someone yelling
out racists, things like that. It
um, there's, there's,
there's a self my own self checking on
that and a lot of times I kind of have to
get over myself like this is,
this is language that I don't
like and can't stand and,
but this character is not me and have
to get to the point where the character
would actually use it.
Yeah. Because that's,
those people are out there and that's
largely what I have to explain with my
affection a ton. Like why would you put
that in your book? That's not funny,
or that's not cool. Like, yes, but
there are people out there who do that.
This is reality. There's really people
like this. So to make the story feel real,
we put these real assholes we have to
deal with every day, put them in the book,
so I'll use them.
What's fascinating to me is the amount
of pushback I get from over on the
publisher side,
the publish side,
you come out with that
language of the character,
like we're going to have to dial that
down. I'm like, he's a Klan member. No,
we're not going to dial that down. He's
burning across, he's a Klan member.
And they'll be like, no, we
can't have that. And like
those are one of the things,
like I mentioned earlier, that's where
things are. I had to put my foot down.
I'm like, that's going in the
book because that's real life.
And people actually say that. And so
that, that can get tricky. But um,
if you're doing horror right
or any kind of writing right,
I think there's a lot of stuff you crossed
that makes you feel super icky. Like,
I,
you know,
am I influencing someone to perform
these kinds of acts by putting it in the
book and the most of the crazy violence
shit that's always in the back of your
head because my books are ridiculously
violent and always in the back of your
head like,
okay,
but what if some day some messed up kid
reads my book and then says I'm going to
go reenact this torture scene on
somebody and am I eventually going to be
responsible for that?
So that's always a thought and
the racist stuff is a thought too,
but largely just you let it roll.
Like if you think that's
what a real person would do
and talk like and act like,
then that goes in the book.
That was the argument when
a American psycho came out.
I read it in the 80s. Um, I, when it
first came out, Bret Easton Ellis,
his book,
it's just really fucking dark.
If you think the movie's
dark with Christian Bale,
it is literally nothing compared to
that book. That book is fucking dark.
And I remember some people that I
knew that had read it who were really
offended, they were really angry and
offended and they were saying like,
this isn't good writing.
He just is describing really fucked
up things that make you uncomfortable.
And then he goes on to the next fucked
up thing and the guy just keeps getting
away with shit. I didn't
see that. Uh, what,
what I saw was this intense view
into a potentially real person.
I mean, there are fucking
serial killers. They do exist.
They have murdered people and
tortured people in horrific ways,
very similar to this character.
So what he's done is drag us into
this really stomach wrenching,
uncomfortable world. This
one intense psycho, right?
And it's fucking masterpiece, I
think. I think it's a masterpiece.
Well going, you know that the, the,
the process of writing in any creative
realm where you're doing film or are you
doing comics are doing books and going
into the bad guy's head and making that
bad guy live and breathe
and feel like a real person.
Part of that process is the bad guy.
Doesn't think he's a bad guy.
The super villain doesn't think
she's a super villain. You know, you,
these people are always morally
justified in everything they do.
They don't go out and commit evil.
They're committing acts that are logical
to them and they're being just in there.
They're committed, you know,
getting revenge or getting
fair desserts on someone.
So being able to write from the
perspective of someone who's doing awful,
horrible shit,
but they don't think it's horrible.
That's one of the tricks to doing it
and that's what he did in that book is,
you know, the, the main character doesn't,
you don't really catch them going,
I'm going to commit acts of evil.
He's just doing what he thinks is what
should be done and wants to do what he
wants and what he needs to do or what he,
as we all do in human beings,
those things we need to do.
We find a way to morally justify them.
Whatever it is that you do that you may
know is a bit squishy in the eyes of
society. There's some,
another part of your head,
the checks and balances system that goes,
it's okay if you do it and here's why
it's even a good thing that you do it and
here's why. And that's, you know, that's
what he did in that book and that's,
that's part of the screwed up,
screwed up part of writing. I mean,
if you're just not writing superficial,
good guy, bad guy snoring Dudley do right,
saves a Dagon,
snidely whiplash and those stories are
perfectly fine and people love them.
But if you're actually trying to get into
the point where you make that bad guy
where you feel for the bad guy
and empathize with the bad guy,
that's tricky stuff.
And my goal at the end of my books
is if there's a showdown between the,
the main,
the bad guy and the good,
the good guy and a bad guy is you're not
really sure who you're rooting for if
you've done it right.
The reader's not really sure
who they want to win that fight,
even though one is morally reprehensible
and the other one is supposedly good.
Well,
you don't want to set up obvious paradigms
and obvious characters that seem to
have been repeated over and over again
throughout time and more complex and
weird and Tony Soprano, like
you can get the, I mean that,
that was like the Sopranos was
one of my favorite shows ever.
And one of the things I really
liked about it was a Tony Soprano.
I was a fucking murderer.
He was an evil scumbag murder that
you were rooting for. Yup. I mean,
it was a very, very, very
fascinating way that they,
they danced with that. And um, I
think what Bret Easton Ellis did in,
in that book was completely unapologetic.
And that's why I found it so fascinating
because the way he described their
horrific, sickening way he described
these crimes was, uh, you know, I mean,
it was so clinical that it almost is
like done in the mind of a psychopath.
Like I didn't even necessarily even enjoy
it. I just think he was really good.
There was parts of that book.
They're like the part where he shows
up to clean up some bodies that he left
behind and the entire apartment
had been cleaned. And uh, he,
he locks eyes with a real estate agent
and the real estate agent is this woman
who's like selling the place and
she's like, I know what you did.
Get the fuck Outta here.
And they exchanged this look,
it's a really fascinating scene of
two monsters running into each other.
You know, one of them were murder or the
other one, a psychopath or sociopath.
And they, that's one of my
favorite parts of that book.
And both of them, I don't remember
that part, but you know, you know,
both of them think that
they did the right thing.
Yeah.
Did the right thing.
It's going to sell that apartment for
fucking 5 million bucks or whatever the
hell it was.
And he's got a,
he was going in there to clean up the
bodies that he left in the tub covered in
acid or whatever the fuck he did. I
forgot what it was. But, uh, yeah,
those, those really evil characters
that you create, that's, uh,
an interesting thing for me
because like, like, like this, uh,
description of the guy coming down
with those headphones on, you know,
the guy's walking down
and people yelling shit.
They're obviously saying angry things.
Like what would they say?
Would they say fuck you? Is that okay?
If you see, would your mouth that right?
Would you mouth? You know, you're
going to die with it. Maybe.
Maybe we'll go with you. We're going
to kill you. You're going to die.
You're going to see him out that, but you
can't say nigger, right? Don't do that.
Evil people.
You make an evil
people. That's fascinating. We
can threaten your life. Right?
And we can get away with like,
we're going to kill you.
They can mouth that in a commercial.
And that's probably okay.
But the other side that's totally done.
No one's going to put that on too.
It's just this fascinating
thing about creating fiction.
The fascinating thing about fiction is,
you know,
when you're creating an evil person,
like what you're saying about will a
person duplicate your ax, will they,
you know, create copycat
crimes? Will they,
will they start like looking into your
way of describing things and recreating
it in a horrific way, in a real world
that you'll feel responsible for?
Whether it's a racist thing,
whether it's a violent thing or
whether it's whatever it is. You know,
that's a fascinating thing to have to
think about when you're creating fiction
is that you,
you may be reinforcing or even perhaps
inspiring an idea that's ultimately very
evil. I think that in the instances
where art has influenced people to go do
something, uh, you know,
those people are looking for that moral
justification even though they don't
know they're doing it. When the night
stalker killer was out, you know, if,
if ACDC hadn't wrote
the song night stalker,
that guy would have found something else.
That guy would have found
something else to, to,
to validate his need to go out and kill.
So that's easy for you to say.
But if he did what you wrote
in your Boobie d yeah. That,
that would be super difficult
to deal with. But I'm, you know,
kind of thought this through several times
cause I write some fucked up shit is,
is, you know, if it happens, how
am I going to feel about that?
And I've already kind of, you know,
like I guess I'm not a bad guy either.
I'm just like the people I'm
talking about. I think a bad guy,
I pre justified that with that guy or
that girl would have found something to
latch onto and would have gone
out and killed based on, you know,
an Anne Rice story instead
of my story. Yeah. I'm,
I'm very fascinated by the influence of,
of something creative like that.
Whether it's a film that inspires like
taxi driver, which inspired John Hinckley.
You know, there's, I'm,
I'm fascinated by that strange
link between a n a creation,
a creative creation that's turned into
a movie or a book and how it influences
people and how you know,
you can catch someone who's got the wrong
fucking chemicals floating around in
their brain and they read any one of
your books and decide to enact a scene.
And there was a guy who was arrested
and in Vancouver for enacting a Dexter
scene. Oh yeah, he was Uighur nerd
that yeah, he fucking killed somebody.
Dexter dumb because I was a huge extra
fan and he wound up killing somebody.
I'm a huge Dexter fan.
I was a huge extra fan of season one.
You didn't like, they got one guy
the best season though. John Lithgow.
Did you not watch that season? I couldn't
watch the, a bad rear naked choke.
This terrible technique.
Listen,
I'm a Jujitsu practitioner. I know what
it looks like when you choke somebody.
It doesn't look like that. That
was terrible. If I was on that set,
if I was on that set, I'd be like,
come here bitch, let me choke you.
I'm going to show you what it feels like
to be choked. You can't act like that.
You can't act like that
when you're choking or where
you're not even squeezing.
Interesting. This is,
I'm sure this is old hat.
You've been on dozens of TV sets that
we did. Our first TV set ever for the,
for justified.
We got to go there.
They're shooting episode number seven
because the people making justified or
interested in making in fact a new series.
So we get to go watch,
you know Timothy Olyphant do his
thing. Uh, and ones that guy, he's the,
he's the Marshall Ones. Wears the
hat. Okay. He testified and he was in,
what was he in before it was deadwood.
He was another guy who
wore a hat and shot people.
And then there's the other
guy that's from the shield,
that really good actor from the shield.
It's in that as well.
I don't know which guy who played
like the, he was one of the cops.
One of the dirty cops. Oh yeah, no, no,
no. That's a Walter Goggins. He, yeah,
he plays a bad guy. Yeah,
he's the two of them.
If you've never watched us by the two
of them together are lights out for the
best deal. The best acting duo
on TV in my opinion. Hands down.
Is that a really good show? It's
amazing. So good. It's so good.
I don't hear about it. I don't catch
in hype. It's, Oh, it's, it's catching.
It started to catch on.
It's head into season five,
which starts tonight actually sees a
five premieres on season five. So I can,
I can start now and I
can get four seasons.
You can get forces an advertisement
for justified and we snuck in an
advertisement. Let's go choking. So
here's, here's why you'd like it.
Here's why you'd like it.
It's basically the character a is a total
psychopath who's wearing a batch and
functions perfectly normal in society.
But when it comes point to arrest the guy,
instead of just pulling the gun and
going, okay, put your hands up. I got Ya.
He leaves the gun in the
holster and he's always like,
I can take in and you're going to serve
life in jail or you can draw that gun
and if you shoot me down,
you get to walk with him anymore.
Don't tell him I don't want to know
this. That's how dare you. I'm sorry.
Spoiler Alert Guy, I'm sorry.
But a son of a B that we got,
we got to go on the set and the and
Timothy old fonts reading the script and
it's very fanboy a super cool. And
then he turns out, he talks to the Mar,
the real Marshall, who's been the
consultant on the show for all four years.
And Timothy asked him a question like,
know I'm a little,
I don't want my guy do this.
And you could see the Marshall
sweating it a little bit,
cause he knows what he's gonna say.
It's going to screw up a lot of work.
And basically he says, yeah, you
wouldn't go from point a, B, c,
D and e to f if you were me,
you would have just gone straight
to FMN done with it. And then they,
you can tell they're now going
to go back and do rewrites.
Much like the John Lithgow thing with
a bad rear naked choke. There's so,
you know, there's so hoping it's
going to be as realistic as possible.
They're going to have to go
change a bunch of crap. Yeah.
That when I saw the rear naked choke,
I thought I was watching like TV show
from the eighties I was watching be a
Vulcan nerve pinch.
It was fucked.
It was volcan nerve pinches more
believable because Elise, she's an alien.
You know John Lithgow cows,
an old man with Shitty biceps
killing some lady in a bath tub.
It's just not even fighting back.
People fight like wild animals when you're
trying to kill them. Yeah, it's crazy.
The unrealistic portrayal of death
that took you out of the story.
That's a good season though. I
agree. That's a really good season.
It starts terrible.
Starts with the worst rear naked
choke seen in the history of TV.
I'm a stickler for technique
when it comes to shows.
Is that the girl he's choking out? Let me
tell you some. It ain't that easy, bitch.
Her whole right side is open.
She can pay
it over there. He doesn't
have Jack Shit. Curl it up.
No that she's not fighting hard enough
for faces and red like you got to.
I would tell them this is a true,
this is a rear naked choke though
for real cause they are in a bathtub.
There's no way,
by the way,
you get into that bathtub without
anybody getting totally wet.
Everybody would be soaking wet.
She'd be fighting for our
life and flopping around.
You wouldn't get behind her naked and
be able to do this. This is ridiculous.
So ridiculous position. It's
just terrible. Season sucks.
I changed my mind crew.
That show fucking bullshit.
I think that Dexter just went,
it started just getting weird started
getting weird and not believable after
like the first season. I feel look
from a, from a creative perspective,
once they got through season two and three
maybe season four it's really hard to
keep that shtick going. He's the serial
killer or killers, serial killers.
There's only so much. The challenges
to that writing team were significant.
How do we keep this going because we're
making money and make the best show we
can it man.
It had to be really hard.
Well the problem is also the
dude stopped looking scary.
If you look at Dexter in season one,
he was yoked. Yeah, he was there.
There were talking about him being like
a martial arts expert and he had this
thick neck and traps and everything and
he looked creepy and scary. You know,
he looked like a guy who
could fuck somebody up,
but you look at him after he
got sick unfortunately he got,
what do you have like leukemia
or something. Like he had cancer,
he had to go through chemo and he was
really fucking skinny for a long time and
then you're like,
well now not buying him rag dolling all
of these people before I bought him as
this really crazy super strong guy who
was also a serial killer and it was just
using his sickness to get
rid of bad people. Just like,
this is a fascinating concept, but
after awhile I was like, bitch,
that's got to say they're holding
back the cough. Yeah. Listen man,
congratulations on everything.
That is a huge,
huge news that you've got these two
things in the works and you know,
wish you all the best
[inaudible] and let me know when,
when your new stuff comes out,
I'd be happy to tweet it for you.
We'll be happy to talk about it on the
podcast suite and we really appreciate it
man.
I was really fun talking to you.
Really insightful too to I love digging
into someone's creative process. Yeah,
it's fun.
Why is showing that gay guy again?
He's a gay guy,
but he's bad ass.
That guy probably has three costs just
to remind people, go to the website,
find that book. Put in the code death
squad. Get that ebook for free. Yes.
Title fight and uh,
Scott Sigler,
they can get you on Twitter at
Scott Sigler and uh, online.
It's got sigrun.com sorry,
a pandemic tour. Uh,
I'm on book tour starting January 18th.
Oh, beautiful. I'm go to the homepage,
Scott sigler.com it's right on the
right sidebar and we will be in la. Uh,
what, what's the date of La
will be in La on the 27th.
So anybody in La come
out January 27th at dot.
Mysterious galaxy mysterious galaxy. What
the fuck is that as a Scifi bookstore?
That sounds awesome. That's pretty
sweet. It's pretty sweet. All right. Uh,
let us know. We'll tweet it will,
we'll let people know. All right.
Thank you very much man. I really
appreciate it. Again, we so many new fans
out of the show and I'm so excited to
be on here. You're going to get more,
I guarantee you matter what you do.
Great stuff and congratulations and
I love watching someone work hard and
watching it pay off. I think it's
very inspirational. Thank you.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to stamps.com go to stamps.com
and before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in j r e and get
$110 bonus offer.
Thanks also to Squarespace,
squarespace.com.
Use the code Joe and the number one and
build your website and then tweet it to
Hashtag pound j r e.
Squarespace and four of you will win a
free year of Squarespace and a cool swag
bag. So enjoy it. You're dirty freaks.
Thanks also to [inaudible] Dot Com O.
N. N. I t. Use the code name, Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
We love the fuck out of you people.
And we will be back tomorrow with
my good friend, Dr. Mark Gordon,
a specialist in traumatic
brain injury and hormones.
And he's going to teach you how to
protect your liver when you drink too much
booze and all kinds of cool shit.
He's a fascinating,
just fucking torrential downpour
of information. This guy.
So tomorrow will be very fun.
All right. Um, until then,
go fuck yourself and uh, keep
it real. Keep it real. Y'All.